tout est
[Musique]
allô allô allô allô allô en tant qu on
t'entend est-ce que tu m'entends
[Musique]
non je t'entends pas hello hello pensé
plus tôt
[Musique]
à suivre
c'est laborieux
est ce qu'on mange
en 1 2 1 2
ouais je n'entends pas c'est un speech
et changement
en 2 1
en 2 3 c'est un test
en chantant quelque chose
lots en
2 ah c'est bon ça marche c'est bon
qu'est-ce qu'il ya mais bon je sais pas
j'ai rien fait moi c'est vrai ouais j'ai
rien fait ah bon c'est étonnant parce
que moi j'ai rien toucher non plus ok
j'ai tapé sur google mais j'ai rien
trouvé alors ok deezer va peut-être que
ça vient après parfois ça vient
longtemps longtemps après tout à l'heure
antoine il a mis du temps
ok ça marche tant mieux dit que ça
marche pas sur mad men
est ce que tu nous entends allô allô
rah [ __ ] n'entend pas aussi ses rôles
ou quoi pourtant on est en direct la ses
marques et direct
voyons si ça marche ça marche ça
fonctionne normalement tu as fait ta
petite pub sur twitter j'ai pu et je
leur ai fait dans l'aprem la vie voilà
ces cinq minutes avant n'hésite pas à
mettre un petit message d qu'antoine et
là on attaque ça marche je peux être le
lien youtube
[Musique]
allez on
dans trois minutes s'il vient nous
rejoindre et piscine elle commencera
tout les 2 millions ok ça marche tente
de faire un petit tweet pour rameuter du
monde d'ouvrir
[Musique]
et normalement nos six sur dix cordes
ok
[Musique]
été hanté en écoutait route et en cash
jackass que deux consoles j'ai fait
attention quand tu parles aux côtes
souffle dans le micro là bas je vais
couper le micro sont plus simples voilà
[Musique]
en tout cas c'est costaud
c'était vraiment un gros tu as fait
c'est super sympa de pouvoir y
participer
bah écoute c'est bien normal on n'est
pas des n'a pas trop le temps de
regarder la nba donc c'est normal qu'on
fasse appel à des gens qui la regarde
plus que nous quoi pour pour les besoins
des équipes ce genre de chose restent
bons et je reviens dans une minute et
puis en attaque ça marche
allez on y va
bienvenue à tous dans ce live sais pas
si vous êtes déjà beaucoup à nous
écouter mais on va commencer puisque on
a un programme chargé
j - deux avant-bras et aujourd'hui pas
moins de sept lits franchise il semble
qu'ils vont succéder au micro sur notre
chaîne youtube d'envergure pour bien
parler de cette draft justement qui
arrivent les objectifs de l'interné non
les attentes sur la draft et donc on
commence par les blenders et c'est lyon
qui est avec nous comment vas-tu liant
ça avec 111 très bien qu'ils saluent à
tout le monde sur le tchat
on va on va faire le tour de la
situation des blazers normalement vous
la voyez si vous êtes sur le live
youtube
notre page envergure c'est d'ailleurs
toi qui a fourni les données qui affiche
et donc on voit la situation
contractuelle des joueurs et c'est un
petit peu floue là je vais essayer que
ce soit moins floues lilian pour les
blenders qu'est ce que tu attends déjà
de l'intersaison en général avant de se
pencher sur la draft à l'intersaison va
surtout devoir faire réussir des petits
coups malin parce qu'on est bloqué au
niveau du cap space com c'est marqué sur
l'écran on n'a que que 5 millions que de
disponible on en aura également des
débits de level pour saigner du minimum
mais en gros va falloir faire un choix
sur tout simplement le joueur qu'on soit
gardée puisqu'on a aminu août curie et
quand air qui sont donc agent libre
apparemment les le front office diriger
un choix se ferait soit entre amis nous
dont on allait birds are alive et où
soir au dîner houde parce qu'on a un
gros manque sur les postes d'ailier et
donc je pense que la décision que veut
faire le front-office sur soie signée
hans et de la va affluer sur
potentiellement le joueur qu'on va
choisir jeudi soir d'accord donc
donc tu si on part sur amine ou est ce
que tu penses que donc pour pour toile
déjà le est ce qu'il ya des gros
contrats parce que hier on a eu beaucoup
de franchise qui comptait faire qui nous
ont dit finalement notre cas on n'est
pas sûr de le garder puisque ça va
peut-être servira à se débarrasser d'un
gros contrat un peu handicapant c'était
le cas de miami c'était le cas de
charlotte c'était le cas peut-être aussi
milwaukee donc donc est ce que c'est le
cas chez vous est ce que par exemple je
sais pas est ce qu'il ya un joueur qui
est un peu un contre un handicap ans et
avec qui on pour attacher un pic de 25
pour éventuellement se délester de mots
de la masse salariale
ouais bien sûr il ya le choix chênois
entre myers léonarde et 22h - barclays
qui rentrent quasiment tous dans leur
dernière un an peut-être avant dernier
pour avoir des contrats je ne sais plus
mais en tout cas cdc sur koné l'ofce va
regarder pour traiter ces jours là et
c'est également pour cela que dans nos
différents work out on a étudié beaucoup
de joueurs du second tour
je pense qu'on veut on veut essayer de
trait dessus pic 25 avec un jour au
contrat expirant pour récupérer
potentiellement à un début de second
tour pourrait descendre un petit peu
c'est ça descendre un petit peu dans
dans la draft
et effectivement c'est peut-être pas une
mauvaise idée c'est ce que les ce qu'on
nous dit aussi sur le chat se
débarrasser d'evan turner et de
meilleurs veinarde alors les deux ça
peut être un peu beaucoup puisque le pic
25 c'est pas non plus une valeur énorme
mais mais ponctuellement un des deux
effectivement ça pourrait être ça
pourrait être pas mal
antoine tu es là you we et il est là il
est là on est en train de parler d'échec
exemple un portail web bien sûr c'est le
quart d'heure breton c'est bien connu le
met il m'a dit ça cet après midi marie
rose c'est bon s'inquiéter tout qui lui
parle de moi mais on peut pas trop
commencé en retard parce qu'on a un
programme chargé mais
je antoine je te charge du live puisque
moi je vais gérer un petit peu les
arrivées sur sur le ring à août donc je
te charge de si on a des questions
évidemment si vous avez des questions
vous les posez sur sur le live youtube
et antoine ne déposera en direct on y
répondra
on continue avec toi lilian donc
peut-être tu disais tu as regardé un
petit peu les work out what would
c'était des joueurs de début de second
tour
est ce qu'il ya eu des noms qui quitte
son revenu assez souvent parmi les
insider pourquoi pas dd non as insistant
bahia notamment louis king qui est le
joueur d'orégon qui revient beaucoup
parce qu'il a le quasi ont le profil
idéal qui comblerait un peu tous les
besoins des bladers il à cette adresse à
trois points pour le spacing il à sept
longueurs pour défendre sur les postes
d'ailier et c'est un freshman donc ni
locher a souvent tendance à choisir a
privilégié des joueurs à potentiel même
si je sais pas si aux alentours du aux
alentours du pic 25 qu'on pourra encore
choisir beaucoup de joueurs à potentiel
mais donc il
louis king je pense mail un petit peu ce
ce mélange entre apports directs par son
par son shooter sa défense et en même
temps une pointe de potentiel on peut
espérer une progression de qu'il n'a
effectué une année au lycée même pas une
année comme r oui parce qu'il était
blessé en début de saison il me semble
ouais c'est ça ensuite on a eu d'autres
joueurs comme katie occupa la lousiane
louis gates d'or a mis hier à ce qu'au
fil qui sont plutôt des joueurs de début
de second tour et mais vraiment louis
kinga je pense un peu tapé dans l'oeil
du front-office antoine on disait avant
que tu arrives que portland pourrait
peut-être utilisé comme comme on le
disait hier pour pas mal d'équipés se
piquent 25 pour se délester de evan
turner ou de meilleurs léonarde qu'on
plutôt des gros contrats et pourquoi pas
mais mais quand même conservé un choix
de draft mettant en gros trade and quoi
dans cette draft à 25 c'est peut-être
pas une mauvaise idée puisque toute
façon entre 25 et 60 nous rappeler mais
c'est un peu
un peu gloubiboulga je demande au
général
je vous rappel c'est un peu gros big up
à la csn après oui mais après est ce que
est ce qu'un pic 25 m vraiment valeurs
kraft
pas sûr je suis pas je suis pas je suis
pas hyper convaincu ça peut la voir si
un prospect du tir 3 est abandonné pour
des raisons médicales par exemple
j'imagine à jeu sous mao khê par exemple
quelqu'un qui veut aller choper en se
disant je m'en fous qu'ils soient qu'ils
les jeunes ont cassé ça ça peut marcher
mais mais voilà je pense qu'il n'y a pas
une énorme valeur mais en plus je peux
dire qu'ils les moyens d'en faire écran
grand chose quoi d'accord alors
parle-nous de louise king puisque
puisque c'est le nom qui revient un
petit peu c'est un peu le local de
l'étape en plus fin entre guillemets
puisqu'il était à l'université d'oregon
fracturé la piste du mois d'août signe
ouais si je peux je me suis un peu
torturé regardez regardez en région
cette année c'était pas jojo mais
effectivement il ya en tout cas ce qu'on
peut dire ce qu'on a vu sous les 2 aussi
c'est que sur le la fin de saison et le
tournoi ncaa il a été il a été bon et
même compte virginia qu'est une grosse
défense puisqu'ils ont affronté virginia
au tournoi tournant final aurait bonne
il s'en est bien sorti il s'en est bien
sorti l'arrivée à trouver des shoots et
quand ils avaient quand il avait un bout
de jours et il arrivait à mettre dedans
donc
donc s'il ya un vrai potentiel il
vraiment très fin il est vraiment très
très faim et je suis pas comme pour
comme pour okpala en fait cédé potentiel
défensif mais pour l'instant c'est pas
des bons défenseurs pour l'instant c'est
pas des bons défenseurs ça c'est pour
moi c'est certain et je sais pas si tu
es d'accord avec moi sur okpala mais
enfin pour moi si on est vraiment sûr du
potentiel pur il a progressé en attaque
mais en défense pas beaucoup en fait
ouais j'suis pas j'achète pas j'achète
pas ou alors il est pas si jeune que ça
qu'ils disent est quand même pas mal de
défauts pour l'instant c'est juste un an
un prospect
enfin c'est juste un sur le potentiel
mais il n'est pas non plus hyper
athlétique quoi c c'est un mec qui a une
grande envergure est capable en très
grand grand chose donc au final je suis
pas non plus un grand grand fan quoi il
il faut vraiment prendre le temps sur
c'est sur ces joueurs là de les
développer
ce ne sera pas du jour au lendemain mais
parmi les noms cucq qu'on a cité dans
les work out l'élu games les schofield
est ce qu'il ya un profil qui te plaît
particulièrement à portland sachant que
donc cette curie romaine et ou de ses
free agent
donc peut-être que sur les postes en
deux ans il y aura il y aura un peu de
place pour pour évoluer l'année
prochaine bah le guen
il a un peu tête brûlée en sait quelque
chose mais mais mais sinon il est quand
même un impact offensif intéressant je
pense qu'il peut apporter une plus value
par rapport à un euro donné woods assez
rapidement je pense je pense que
défensivement et des meilleurs
offensivement idée certainement plus
polyvalent je pense donc donc j'aime
j'aime pas parce qu'au fil de moi je
voudrais cependant 45 personnellement
donc moi et moi non plus même pas avant
55 c'est vraiment à un poste 3-4 très
petit quoi
ample et et sur les pauvres on ne vit
pas du tout comprendre à un poste à 2
parce que même si c'est qu'on resigne
europe certainement pas cette tuerie je
pense que l'organisation veut donner pas
mal de minutes à en faire une série
bones qu'on a drafté l'an dernier
d'accord thiam en irak
ouais je pense parce qu'il a montré
quelques flashs vraiment intéressant la
saison dernière
vraiment il a joué quelques il a
beaucoup joué de garbage time
mais par exemple le dernier match de la
saison face aux kings où il met plus de
30 points
je ne sais pas je connaissais pas ce
joueur j'ai vraiment vu quelques flashs
au shoot au et dans le dribble qui me
font croire que tout est toujours
d'effectifs le sens donc je pense qu'il
aura une danse à 10 quinzaine de minutes
l'an prochain oui absolument
c'est quelque chose qui est intéressant
à relever puisque c'est vrai que c'est
normal qu'il ait pas beaucoup de temps
de jeu cette année c'est un joueur qui
est pas passé par la case n 6 et 1
antoine conte de fées roni size
c'est un peu loin pour nous mais
exactement besta l'an dernier il était
de rester coi 26-27 un truc comme ça
chez lui quand quelque chose comme ça 24
ouais bah c'est une draft typique
typique blazers squale a juste sur le
potentiel
oui c'est ça
du coup ça me ça m'étonnerait pas que ce
soit du duo copala ou du genre de joueur
qui soit mais c'est vrai quand fourni
simone se bat c'est une bonne surprise
au final
ouais mais les lions du coup est-ce que
ça va avec la timetable comme on dit le
planning des bladers de draft et des
joueurs à potentiel qui vont éclore que
dans deux trois quatre ans l'île heard
et mccollum sont ne seront peut-être pas
là pour toute la vie qua non pour moi
non il faut vraiment un joueur qui
puisse impacter maintenant là il pas
comme tu l art des mac l'homme là ils
sont actuellement dans leur prime et
vont faire que de progresser pendant
encore un ou deux ans et il faut
vraiment les entourer pour pour gagner
maintenant quand on a eu ça nous a donné
un peu d'appétit de faire la finale de
conférence cette année et je pense pas
que l'organisation vous souhaite
s'arrêter en si bon chemin même si ça
sera bien sûr difficile de
de réitérer pareille performance
absolument donc elle quel serait ton
scénario idéal pour toi jeudi soir alors
en restant un petit peu réaliste mais
vraiment le scénario idéal le coût que
pourrait arriver à faire portland grâce
grâce à la draft
moi j'ai un peu deux scénarios et vidéos
en quelques heures c'est soit le premier
se serait si on trade lepic qu'on arrive
à se débarrasser d'un contrat expirant
en ramassant un second tour de draft
et si on décide au final de le garder ce
serait d'avoir des prospects qui chute
des prix se fait intéressant qui sud
comme porteur junior qu'elle donne
johnson ou ou je ne sais pas noël par
exemple mais c'est un petit peu et qui
se retrouvent prof communes comme une
fleur on l'a un peu par chance et qu'on
se dise allant saute dessus quoi et est
ce que tu as des questions justement sur
quelques quelques prospects nous
soumettre il va je ferai un peu savoir
sur votre big board en 25 un joueur qui
qui pourrait apporter le meilleur joueur
qui pourrait apporter tout de suite
or 25 qui vous pensez qu'il sera encore
là moi pour pour vous sincèrement je
dirais eric pascal parce qu' en terme de
besoin ça correspond c'est un poste
c'est un poste 4 2 3 4 qu'apportent les
petites tâches du quotidien les écrans
les le petit travail de long en fait
c'est un bosseur et je pense que ça
conviendrait pas mal à une équipe avec
mccolo mais del arte quoi pas pour moi
j'aime bien aussi
moi j'aime bien brasse des kiss à ce
niveau-là de la draft en laye york ait
workout aussi j'aime bien brasse des
keys parce que c'est un joueur dur
pareil dit la place formaliser de pas
avoir le ballon dans les mains
je pense que c'est un joueur qui a
vraiment un état d'esprit qui est fait
pour au moins devenir un rôle player
correct en nba
après il y aura peut-être du cam johnson
ce niveau là et puis qui vont glisser
mais que j'ai plus haut fin qui vont
être à ce niveau là mais que j'ai plus
haut dans mon board
il ya il ya grant williams qui peut
glisser un complètement possible qu'ils
arrivent jusqu'à vous et là là c'est un
peu pareil que eric pascal mais en
peut-être un peu mieux un peu moins de
garanties aux shoots mais un peu mieux
sur tout le reste et daris basly qui a
pas joué en nba cette année et qui pour
le coup lui aussi peut glisser être
éventuellement des styles de cette draft
qui est un poste 3-4 un peu créateur qui
peut défendre sur plusieurs positions
le genre de joueurs qui ont la côte dans
une bille en ce moment quoi donc voila
un petit peu ce qu'on peut te dire là
dessus
est ce que tu as dit aux 2 questions 1
question supplémentaire oh non je vais
juste dylan ou midler a fait un mort
kaout avec donc j'ai pas forcément
d'informations sur lui à benghazi
antoine bell monte on en a parlé
rapidement il passait ses séjours de
belmont qui joue le fuzz de troie qui
est très très fort shooteur de rêver un
peu peu rebondi un peu
enfin pour boucler très bien dans ce
sens disait hier donc donc il ya pas mal
aimé je penchais chez wind l'heureux 6
je pense ça c'est une bière et dit même
si dès que tu lui mets un mec athlétique
en face il a tendance à lesquels rien
pourquoi
voilà voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire les
liant merci je crois que je crois que
loïc est arrivé pour les warriors ce
qu'ils nous entendent ce qu'on l'entend
non bon ben on va rester avec nous un
petit peu de biens du coup à l'eau alors
oui oui on t'entend on est un peu au
fond de ta cap ça va mieux
west inc c'était ton casque très bien et
bien dans ce cas là on remercie lilian
qui s'en va merci beaucoup a surtout au
boulot merci aux blazers france @
bladers france c'était c'était lilian on
passe donc aux warriors bon qui sait
gentil d'être avec nous une semaine
après la après la défaite en finale
terrible ça y est vous arrivez à passer
à autre chose
voilà le rêve enfants c'est vrai que
c'est un peu la fin d'une époque à
golden state un ouais en fait c'est une
défaite plus les blessures donc sait
conjuguer gras oui absolument
c'était une défaite ça irait mais il ya
eu absolument et c'est marrant enfin
c'est marrant le compte de nichane fr
bottes ttc c'est pas toi directement
métier tu les connais dans les analyses
que vous pouvez voir là sur le live dans
les analyses objectives dans
l'intersaison c'était quel avenir pour
qu'heidi clay et cousines et bien
l'avenir l'avenir hospitalier d'entre
eux quoi mais mais bon du coup malgré
cela malgré malgré un été enfin un début
d'été du coup un peu compliqué un prêt
était qu'est ce que tu peux attendre
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre de la
draft du côté des warriors est ce qu'on
fait comme d'habitude c'est à dire qu'on
draft un mec qui est plutôt nba ready
même si john evans est pas un franc
succès
ces conditions oui il n'a pas beaucoup
joué donc je peux vraiment l'opportunité
de prouver non plus mais dans le
contexte voir ailleurs c'est difficile
de lui donner du temps du bois ouais bon
après du coup de l'année prochaine
peut-être que peut-être peut-être que
donc du coup voilà ma question pour la
draft que comment tu l'envisagent toi en
tant que fan vous pouvez aussi et nous
dire ce que vous en pensez sur le chat
commet tour est ce que tu vois
l'intersaison des warriors la haye ce
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire avec ce pic
28 et il ya le 58 aux cimes on en
parlera peut-être un peu plus tard
honnêtement c'est un peu flou lorsque en
fait j'aime beaucoup dont il ya beaucoup
de cris à john ont les trois quarts du
mans son agent
dans ce cas pas dans le cas où ils
veulent rareté j'ai envie de dire que ce
sera automatiquement à l'extérieur parce
que l'uni je pense qu'il va je pense
qu'il va signer ouais ben gordon bell
sera restricted ça je ne sais pas ce
qu'ils vont faire
il ya toujours le projet des mines jones
qui est viable pas viable je sais pas
mais mais je pense qu'ils ont ils ont
ils ont envie de de persévérer avec ça
parce que ce que je pense qu'ils vont
grave c'est un ailier ou un bond en
arrière de ce que j'avais vu j'aimais
bien
cameron johnson ouais j'suis pas ce que
vous en pensez mais ça serait étonnant
qui glisse jusqu'à 28 je crois qu'il en
ait la cote quand même mais mais après
nous nous ni veau de nos bornes ça
correspond à peu près 1 cameron johnson
à ce niveau là la draft antoine je passe
tu confirmes août infirme
bob johnson il est dans le quatrième
chapeau qui va de 13h à 46,45 donc
serait que sa cote en ce moment elle est
un peu un poil plus haute souvent je
vois en vain
entre 20 et 25 mai cédé 100,28
franchement ça m'étonnerait pas du tout
alors du coup qu'est ce que tu peux
répondre qu'est ce que tu en penses
niveau 2 sont à une bière guinness on va
dire je fais actuellement n'est pas
forcément fan de joueurs mais mais il ya
quand même des choses à aimer ouais je
suis pas très fan du joueur parce que
c'est un chanteur un shooter quoi
entamer mexes castagne quoi c'est un
shooter très strict qui sait donc ce
souhait il va faire un six sur huit sur
un match où il va faire 1 0 sur 5 quoi
tu sais pas trop toujours ce que tu vas
voir au début du match donc moi ça me
pose un problème ce genre de joueur
personnellement surtout qu'il a 23 ans
donc autant dire qu'il est un peu il un
put usagers oui mais oui il ya
l'expérience d'avoir joué dans un gros
programme d'avoir une place importante
dans un gros programme dense carolin
n'est ce pas n'importe où voilà il est
quand même je pense près avoir quelques
minutes alors peut-être pas beaucoup
beaucoup mais mais oui ils n'ont pas
beaucoup progressé et ça c'est sûr mais
voilà l'avantagé qu'il amènera du
shooting un peu supplémentaire puisqu'on
a bien vu dans les finales que c'est un
peu s'éteindre à compliquer en dehors de
clés et écuries et c'est un peu
compliqué quoi et du congo étant plus
facile de défendre sur le coin du coup
ça peut ça peut être intéressant
effectivement mais je suis pas sûr qu'il
jouera énormément énormément dans qu est
ce que tu as vu d'autres n'ont passé
loïck au niveau des work-outs parce
qu'il ya d'autres joueurs qui sont un
peu intrigué qui te font dire pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas chez nous ouais il ya 8
king vous en parler avant ouais
apparemment il est pas vraiment une me
reding s'est un peu compliqué signate
darius base lait qui m'intrigue un peu
aussi après je ne sais pas s'il est
vraiment nba ready et j'ai regardé un
petit peu quelques highlights de lui et
j'ai trouvé son shoot un peu curieux
enfin sa mécanique de shoot un peu
curieuse je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez
ouais c'est passer par un shooter c'est
un shooteur nekoi way clairement mais je
ne sais pas trop quel est ce qu'il est
vraiment prêt ou non puisque ben ali l'a
pas fait de deux saisons en
universitaire mais lee il a fait un très
bon combat il est arrivé aux combines
les le couteau entre les dents il est il
et c'est lui qui avait le plus faible
taux de masse graisseuse je crois de
tout le plateau
donc c'est vraiment déjà ses boeing
comme mon professionnalisme du mec qui
s'est préparée tout seul pour le coup
ouais
et puis les des qualités il un banquier
basket hills est pas un c'est pas un
vrai shooteur puisque lui son shoot
c'est plus de dribbles que me disent les
les français dribbler avec un poulet à
4,5 m plus qu'un shoot et catch and
shoot 2 à 3 mais il mais il apporte une
aide du qi basket c'est puis un peu de
plémet king et j'avoue moi j'aime bien
tous les besoins ouais moi aussi j'aime
bien je crois que je l'aimé d'ailleurs
aux warriors dans ma dent may moque sur
le site
c'était le consensus c'est le consensus
en plus c'est pas étonnant parce que
dans l'ensemble ben l'aiment bien
antoine l'aiment bien moi aussi moi je
les bourses que je le disais juste avant
j'ai bien plus haut dans mon board et
dans ma tête
darius base les manteaux réparé andre
iguodala
c'est plutôt cool plutôt pas mal
après après ce but comme dit antoine on
sait pas vraiment si les ready et ce qui
est sûr c'est que tout n'est pas
totalement prêt après la saison
régulière on sait que c'est une histoire
complètement différente des playoffs
donc donc pour la saison régulière ça
peut ça peut suffire je sais pas c'est
sale c'est qu'on sait pas trop comment
ça va se passer l'année prochaine c'est
quoi être projeté en début de saison si
idée parce que déjà à l'arrière qui ce
sera parce que celui qui est essentielle
là c'était de chenilles stone mais il y
aura peut-être une retraite non jeu ça
va dépendre le 5 à part curie dreyman
green tête damien jones
en dehors de ça j'en ai aucune idée
noda est encore là je crois vigoda là
haut mais il use as que en saison est
levée en côtes rigoureux ouais il
hiberne un peu saison régulière quand
même ouais absolument donc ouais c'est
pas c'est pas évident à projets ça vous
aiderait bien d'avoir un gars qui peut
vous donner au moins 20 minutes quoi
c'est sûr mais surtout ont amené liés en
fait parce que depuis deux 2 ans on va
dire il manque clairement de profondeur
à l'ale choix que si l'année dernière
rigaud d'alex blesse même avec qui il
dit
quand les grains houston jouer small
ball et oublie de mettre à l'intérieur
sur le terrain c'était compliqué il a
cette année avec bon et qui dit aussi il
ya le talent qui est dit même si c'est
compliqué de m andre iguodala 35
défendre sur le meilleur extérieur on
peut se demander de de mettre ses shoots
ouverts c'est compliqué un mois un
ailier on est lié donc donc après alors
l' avantage c'est que à ce moment là de
la draft on n'en manque pas normalement
oui on n'en manque pas c'est à dire que
alors à temps parce que je suis en train
de naviguer mais
mais voilà il ya match style alors qu'il
va peut-être pas glissé jusque là mais
on parlait juste avant de idy brasse des
tice peut aller chercher on peut aller
chercher si on s'y plonge un petit peu
après c'est un peu des rich mais on peut
aller chercher des desserts desservi 10
on peut aller chercher des jordan pulque
plus sur le post deux ans voilà il ya un
peu de jours mais un bon choix mais ça
serait étonnant qu'il ya un joueur
vraiment fort qui glisse way puisque
jusqu'à la cua ça serait crédits photo
mo jeunes entre 15 et 30 ce sens ouais
en gros en gros il ya bon baillet les
ien après il ya en 2 3 ça peut fixer
aussi ensuite il ya une fourchette de 7
juillet a qui vont partir peut-être un
peu plus 7 8 10 gars donc effectivement
tu vas jusqu'au jusqu'à la fin de
loterie et après après pour moi il ya
une autre notre barrière en différentes
13 et 25 il ya une fourchette de joueurs
et après 25 à une autre et là on est en
plein dedans quoi donc
il a fort bien draft et il va falloir
bien choisir il va falloir il va falloir
avoir du nez ils vont pas fait justement
entre jordan belle bosse depuis qu'ivan
louis en baie des miennes je ne sais pas
trop mais jacques aubé vice et à jacob
evans pardon j'ai dit moi qui étais à
cincinnati que j'aimais bien antoine je
crois que tu fais mais moins bien mais
je l'aimé bien dès qu'ils giacobbe evans
ah ouais ouais j'aimais bien assis très
bien je serai qu'il était plus haute
était plus que nous sur sur giacobbi
hunt mais les gens en général e les
warriors draft bien ils vont chercher du
talent un kévin monnet il s'est pas fait
en un jour n'ont pu y avait du talent on
avait bien aimé ce pic de mémoire à
l'époque et voilà quoi ça a bien marché
je pense qu' est-ce que tu as un pli
catalan alors 28 là un truc
pour du coup les heures juste avant sur
du claxton je pense ça fait vraiment
très très loin mais bon voilà je pense
que tu t'amuses base lait ou du tuquoi
gvg par non tyler héros je crois
énormément il va peut-être partir avant
il va partir avant je pensais juste dans
mamma qui les lie très bas mais ils se
basent les je le sens bien je pense
qu'on va y avoir bataille sûr d'aller se
baserait sur l'épique 25 à 30 c'est
possible c'est possible après klaxons
peut glisser parce que à ce niveau-là de
la draft ce qu'on disait hier un bon
après c'est pas là où il ya le plus de
besoins quand même ce que tu disais loïc
niveau des postes
post 4 5 mais à ce niveau-là d'agrément
plusieurs quand même qu'ils sont un peu
dans la même fourchette kabange
exton ghafour de fernando c'est un peu
tout donc alexander walker ou ce serait
incroyable qui tombent d'accord mais
même alors là je fonce dessus
enfin moi en tous cas me demande mon
avis moi j'y vais les yeux fermés en 28
nm en vain d'ailleurs
ok là qu est ce que l'on y croit et
allumé oui d'allumer et d'éteindre son
micro texte ce type de sa lumière dont
on entend des bruits de saucisson du
prémâché jacub evans non pour que c'est
quoi
valider son ouvrage j'ai moi aussi bas
ça c'est sûr je disais mais bon c est ce
que ça vaut le coup et ce qu'il aurait
assez de temps de jeu avec queen kuffor
mcqueen coup tu demandais pourquoi pas
tu peux je suis pas hyper pas hyper
convaincu que ce soit le type de
prospects qui soit se règle très
variance puisqu'il est le potentiel max
je trouve pas ou personnellement le
nickel ouais il est pas hyper athlétique
dit pas non non non mais ça peut être un
bon cinquième élément d'une équipe qui
gagne quoi oui peu des peines
mais après c'est toujours problème avec
avoir reçoit avec le tout va dépendre de
kieffer signes et c est comment avoir du
temps de jeu et comment faire progresser
ses jeunes joueurs que oui et oui c'est
un peu le problème
loïc est ce que tu as une autre question
pour finir non non non c'est à dire
comment sorti depuis toute façon c'est
compliqué après de d'essayer de voir que
certains prospects dans le sens via le
bonze parce qu'il sera l'an prochain et
majeur donc un profil peut-être pour le
le petit 50 loup qui vous le gardez ce
qui s'est fait un combo guard un combat
noble west wing ou de l'est pas ah oui
vous avez quand même beaucoup
enfin le prix du baril brent
quel beau mais bon c'est pas de réseau
grève qui fait ça
de quoi toi aussi parce que c'est moi
coc coin je ne sais pas tu sais pas qui
c'est au-delà olsenboye mois notre bon
j'ai fait ça donne un effet drainant
merci d'avoir été avec nous avons incité
ce que c'est que nous connaissons
scénario le real quand même bon je dis
ça à chaud la libye jeudi
on va déjà merci à vous c'était cool et
pour la draft
je pense que en fait tout simplement
d'avoir un ailier ce serait ce serait
l'idéal
après difficile de voir le potentiel et
le profil exact mais un ailier ou un
extérieur ce trailer plutôt un ami
communes du réolais lepic 28 c'est vrai
mon éclairage et la draft est un bon
joueur de rotation est le 28 c'est une
bonne solution
et bien je te remercie d'avoir été avec
nous on appelle de notre ami daniel way
salue les kings prodigués lots
m'entendais c'est bon on entend très
bien aux qui a dit qu'elle salut à tous
vous avez trois trucs au deuxième tour
et qu'il sait ça alors avant avant de
parler de cette draft est ce que tu peux
nous nous évoquer les objectifs de
l'intersaison pendant que pendant que je
vais je vais changer la page et on va
voir un petit peu
les objectifs justement de l'intersaison
que vous nous avez décrit avec le comte
sacramento fr comment ça s'annonce pas
forcément à la draft mais pour les kings
en règle générale sur l'intersaison de
manière générale je pense qu'on va
chercher à se positionner sur un meneur
backup est un pivot non moins besoin de
ce meneur backup parce que de ce que
j'ai entendu il se murmure que youri
ferrell et mason serait pas forcément
conservé ou que du moins un des deux
serait pas conservé par qu'on aurait
besoin d'un meneur make-up ses
distributeurs pour créer derrière fox
sur le banc et il ya toujours ce mystère
autour de autour de colis stein sait
toujours pas si si on va leur signer sur
lui filer un contrat s'il va se barrer
ou quoi donc
dans l'éventualité il nous faut une fois
évidemment qui vaut de préférence
approché le profil défense défense
rebond quoi est-ce que marvin bagley
peut pas être votre pivot demain dans ma
vie ma gueule et ça me semble on ça me
semble un peu léger pour jour le poste
de pivot
là l'heure actuelle il doit vraiment
prendre beaucoup plus de co plus de
force qu'on puisse de muscles pour jouer
pivot je pense qu'il est et ça peut il
peut jouer pivot par séquences mais
c'est pas une solution viable sur le
long terme ce moment il va me peu trop
galéré face à certains un gros big man
de la france ouais antoine nom mais dont
on va rester actuelle y est donc du coup
tu disais un backup
wanggaard faut un meneur et et donc
éventuellement un pivot mais alors un
pivot titulaire au deuxième tour c'est
compliqué ah ouais non la sueur là je te
parle vraiment de l'intersaison je pense
que sur la draft ce positionnement est
plutôt way soit soit sur un mineur soit
sur un poste 3 en fait construire en
poste 3 va surveiller
est ce que pour pour toi ils vont pas
garder les trois ils vont pas de
racheter les trois ils vont pas bien ou
deux c'est peu probable oui il ya des
chances qu'on qu'on cherche un dump
un ou deux des pics ou éventuellement a
trait au top pour aller chercher un
honneur aux premiers joueurs au premier
tour qui c'est mais assez peu de chance
quand on conserve les trois les trois
choix je vois mal voit mal comment on
pourrait intégrer trois joueurs
aujourd'hui dans l'effectif
je pense que c'est pas c'est pas jouable
ouais donc on va se concentrer sur du
alors frank meehan il vous a étrenné
nous pas dans les plans ben en fait
l'heure il se murmurait que il n'était
pas feinte sans dire que qui allaient
être coupées que ce n'était pas une
priorité que des joueurs comme ferrell
emerson ces dégâts qui dépannait bien
derrière fox mais que ce n'était pas
forcément des solutions solutions très
solide
d'après a passé un palier alors qu'elle
quel profil recherché ce que c'est
plutôt un gars un peu solide en défense
distributeur est ce que c'est plutôt un
gap justement peut peut accélérer le jeu
à la même manière que dit que diane fox
je pense je pense qu'avant tout on a
besoin de vraiment de
un gars qui s'est créée en fait c'est le
gros problème qu'on avait qu'on avait
cette saison c'est que dès qu'il y avait
plus phoque sur le terrain on a plus de
créateurs alors soit sur des par
séquences étaient bogdanovic qui prenait
qui prenait un peu le truc en main mais
on n'a pas vraiment de postes un
créateur qui vient du banc en fait c'est
vraiment le problème qu'on avait c'est
que ça pouvait parfois joué vraiment
désorganisé fait que votre guide nos
vies chat dans un mauvais jour ou que
l'on s'y retrouve plus ça peut vite être
le bazar
donc je pense qu'avant des défenseurs
évidemment c'est bien qui peut jouer up
tempo évidemment c'est bien mais je
pense qu'avant tout il nous faut
quelqu'un qui sache créé qu'ils
s'agissent tribu ça se trouve pas sous
le sabot d'un cheval ainsi c'est vrai
que deux français sur le chat on nous
dit que pour le poste de pivot il ya
maggetti salomone ce très beau pseudo
dit andré jordan à la free agency basse
et je pense que c'est clairement le pas
forcément lui en particulier mais c'est
le profil de pivot sur lequel on pouvait
se positionner quoi voilà leur rebond
d'heure exactement c'est exactement ça
je pense exactement ce qu'il nous faut
c'est exactement ce qu'il manque un
colis stein aujourd'hui c'est finalement
c'est comme un mec longiligne athlétique
mais il n'a pas envie de protéger le
cercle de prendre trop de rebonds
donc voilà c'est vraiment le en a besoin
de sommes de ce poste pivot titulaire
qui prend des rebonds et qui défend on
ne va pas le chercher un scoreur ou quoi
que ce soit mais je pense qu'on a
vraiment besoin d'un mec qui est qui
regroupe qui défend et pour le backup en
gardons
nous glisse cette core i7 curie le frère
de clément
on l'a vu juste avant il est il
effectivement free agent
il est frais il n'est pas protégé a
cette fois là bas serait un petit un
petit retour à la maison on est resté un
petit passage un petit passage à
sacramento ya quelques années on a vu
qui a fait des playoffs des pilotes très
intéressant avec avec portland il a été
très solide très assez bon scoreur et
arles il a redit qu'il a peut-être je
pense que c'est une solution
intéressante effectivement mais ça va
peut-être qu'il va demander après vous
avez du cap
ouais où il ya du cap oui mais
clairement l'objectif c'est de pouvoir
signer plusieurs joueurs dont je pense
que maintenant si on s'est désolidarisé
de l'autre sur route chez beach c'est
qu'on veut pas mettre trop d'argent sur
un seul mec quand tu ne diras c'est pas
l'heure c'est pas le même type de
salaire même plus mais c'est mais je
pense qu'on cherche plus à prendre des
joueurs de complément avec des salaires
moyens voire bas et les voilà pour
pouvoir aussi des nôtres notre effectif
est l'été prochain antoine tu as eu le
temps de réfléchir un petit peu sur les
pics donc soit 40 soit 47 soit 60 au
choix un meneur distributeur un peu
créateur qui défend pas trop mal est-ce
que tu as le das dans ma besace le
meilleur meneur distributeur que je
pourrais avoir ça se rayer soit du
justin robinson soit john holmes
j'avais entendu passer le nom de justin
robinson justement moi je crois qu'on en
dise corde avec la communauté king il ya
des gars qui avaient évoqué cette
possibilité
ouais c'est un bon distributeur il
connaît déjà il est prêt c'est pas ça
sera jamais une star un ce mec
c'est beau non mais ce n'est pas lui
faire injure que de dire ça oui heureux
c'est juste pas son jeu du coup du coup
voilà j'avais une autre vie peut-être
très monde soit heures ce qui est très
petit mais que j'aime bien moi
personnellement je me bats là pour le
coup pour créer c'est vrai que c'est un
des rares meneur du second tour qui est
vraiment créateurs qui créent des
différences il est très rapide très
crafty il shoote bien ils arrivent ils
arrivent balayé les tout-petits quoi
mais il arrive à aller au cercle y perd
facilement par rapport à ces sa taille
quoi enfin je veux dire il devrait pas
être si difficile que ça défendre mais
vraiment il est même aux compagnies
semblent antoine qui là ils étaient ou
pas why était une simple qui l'a montré
avec vue sur pick'n roll il avait une
facilité assez assez dingue a juste
trouvé des lignes de drive dans la
raquette quoi je ne sais pas si elle te
condamne je maquille angelico mbaye
niang c'est peut-être ça ne s'était
peut-être geely comme magna sans que ses
fins le défunt je sais plus j'ai pu j'ai
puissant mais moi mais mail il réussit à
rendre meilleur l'équipe de lucio il y
avait quand même un peu des têtes
brûlées quoi et des compagnies ce n'est
pas compliqué à organiser
et c'était certainement le meilleur
défenseur de l'équipe d'air le maquis
chez saint-pierre
c'est vraiment très petit en chaussures
je crois oui c'est ça il est réussi
c'est comme à être le meilleur défenseur
de l'équipe - ouais c'est yannick haut
sur le chat qui nous dit que quand on
sait en parle beaucoup je lomé outre
atlantique de très bonnes twitter
apparemment je passais les les insiders
ce genre de choses j'en ai pas trop hein
pas trop vu passer là pas vu passer ce
genre de chose toi bon tout cas voilà
plusieurs mondes
j'ai vu passer par contre d'une
possibilité avec chameau ripples alors
que ça leur titre s'ils arrivent jusqu'à
40 c'est pas mal
alors antoine est moins fan que moi de
moins en moins je crois plus l'année
avance ouais mais bien en début d'année
mais là j'ai commencé j'ai saturé quoi
savoir ippon c'est un meneur qui pour le
coup fait une taille correcte il n'est
pas grand mais une taille près correct
il est long donc il projette plutôt bons
défenseurs peu meilleur que waters alors
il n'y a pas la latéralité le côté peau
pot de colle kaka très bonne potters en
défense mais mais il est peut-être plus
en plus présents sur les lignes de
passes genre de choses et puis on
attaque il avait quand même un gros une
grosse cote apporter à tous tout
reposait sur lui à saint john et donc et
donc qu'il a il s'en est pas trop mal
sorti à ce compte là puisqu'il perdait
pas tant de ballons que ça il crée il a
je crois que son ratio à 6 turnovers est
plutôt bon de tête de mémoire et par
rapport aux taux d'usagé toujours
comparer avec ça et puis et puis c'est
un singe shooter un peu strict y aussi
antoine 1 ça que tu aimes - je dis c'est
sais ce que c'est ce qui me dérange
c'est que healy
il peut exploser complètement il pleut
il pleut il pu scorer 40 poing dans la
gueule de l'équipe adverse contre à peu
près n'importe qui je pense est il ya
des matches où il va faire 3 sur 21 aux
shoots et c'est une catastrophe
inconstant longtemps extrait extrêmement
constante dans sur le tir et dans le jeu
après ça c'était peut-être aussi une
conséquence du rôle qu'il avait à saint
john ouais mais c'est l'équipe de st
john's sincèrement était pas si nul que
ça il y avait des joueurs que j'aimais
bien c'est un peu difficile
voir il y avait des jeux bref il y avait
des joueurs à ce titre il y avait des
mecs qui pouvaient planter sur les
postes 2 3
l'ofc et justin hines aux jeux c'est
plus c'est pas grave mais il y avait il
y avait sur certains matches d'etg pense
notamment au first for c'était c'était
un peu chaud quoi c'est franchement si
tu es un peu jory c'est vraiment
n'importe quoi
oui oui oui mais sur ce match là que tu
as commencé à l effet ces points bernard
voilà donc mais après 40 se serait
probablement une bonne pioche sur a plus
beaucoup de joueurs de ce standing l'a40
en fin de ce standing supposé ça parle
de kayes dans le tchat
ouais ouais paraît-il qu'on a lui a fait
faire de workout deux que je crois qu'il
passait et vérifier sa sueur sur
envergure point c'est au met
effectivement en plus vous voulez trois
piques au second tour kai kai
on en a parlé plusieurs fois et là c'est
il faut rendre antoine ce qui est
antoine c'est lui qui qu'il a choisi
comme style de cette draft
c'est vraiment le joueur le cingle ou
gaye du second tour ouais en gros
donc à temps j'étais en train de
chercher quoi le workout braqueurs mais
j'ai vu qu'une fois dans les dents et
workout mais j'ai pas encore des genres
actualisé oui j'ai fait un peu ce matin
sur les work out de la loterie mène sans
rajouter et d'ailleurs darus garlande
work out avec les knicks exactement -
faute dernière minute qui est un peu
déstabilisante pour no no big board
john kosar vous avez workout aussi un
joueur qui jouait dans une toute petite
fac à fort twin aucun bon shooteur
notamment pour cet accord j'ai
confirmation de quelques cassures sur le
note discorde justement qui qui nous dit
que effectivement calgary bien passé
deux fois au work out à sacramento une
fois début juin il une fois hier
apparemment hier 1
donc ça sent bon quand même ouais voilà
c'est ça a l'air d'être un profil trop
profil auquel on s'intéresse moins ça
nous ferait plaisir vous draft et kaka
higuain on va suivre ça avec intérêt
ouais c'est un bon qui sait vraiment
manqué que je pense pour absolument 5
rahmani vous en avez workload des gens
ouais il ya du monde qui est passé entre
15 et 20 work out j'ai pas tout suivi
il ya eu du geste in right for man il a
pour rôle backup point guard peut être
intéressant d'udine wade qu'on aime
beaucoup et là et plus du backup 4 quoi
donc c'est moins peut-être moins
intéressant pour vous voilà c'est
vraiment vraiment sûr du meneur sur du
bonheur ou que je pense surtout après
marianne chaillac brian powell le
chouchou de ben aussi intéressant voilà
on m'a parlé de lise ailleurs obligé
isaiah robbie c'est c'est pas mal du
tout mais alors c'est plus un poste
347.4 ouais c'est il est grand il est
grand il est costaud
il défend vraiment bien par séquences il
pas été d'une régularité à toute épreuve
mais quand même c'est un bon défenseur
pour sa taille il est vraiment très
mobile il est plutôt costaud et il a des
aptitudes un peu il vit pousse la balle
assez facilement il un drive est assez
fluide par rapport à suis dans un 3 4 de
ce niveau là de la draft on va dire la
grosse question c'est son tir qui a
vraiment pas progressé quasiment du tout
pendant ses années à l'université
antoine que confirmer mes dires ouais
ouais ouais mais je pense qu'il ya moyen
d'en faire quelque chose d'aussi way
absolument il ya en tout cas il ya là un
bosseur voilà c'est un bosseur il ya les
capacités athlétiques
il ya là il ya la matière après il faut
il faut voir ce qu'on en fait du côté
des équipes de développement des kings
ce qu'on en ferait quoi voilà après faut
être vous faut se dire aussi que les
équipes même si elles ont des besoins
des deux resteront surtout sur le jury
ait préféré oui si ça correspond à un
besoin s'en contente mais sinon la
plupart s'en foutront sauf quand même
quelques exceptions tu vois je sais pas
les les kings ils ont peut-être pas
drafté un poste de quoi ils ont ils des
et bogdanovic noah s'est très
probablement pas très difficile de lui
donner du temps de jeu après ses cahiers
drafté tu as toujours tu as toujours
moyen de trouver une rotation de de
compléter pas ce que vous appelez ya
toujours des blessures thérapie de façon
ce que jusque les gemmes ils veulent
c'est c'est une valeur marchande
quasiment quoi donc si le maire la
meilleure valeur marchande serge marquis
qui correspond pas forcément un besoin
de l'équipe basso vide quoi je pense
absolument une dernière chose avant de
de passer la main je sais pas si le
l'invité suivant est déjà arrivé mais
une dernière chose on dans le chat on
évoque john ford ou kings tout ce que tu
en penses antoine on évoque qui au
king's puisque ça a coûté john horde de
français il a esquivé work out je sais
même pas si la régie j'étais dessus mais
je suis pas sûr que ce soit un joueur
idéal pour eux ouais je pense soit
situation d'y être pour le gilet noir de
mon club si la work out absolument le
1er juin
mais là bas
ainsi s'ils pensaient voilà que c'est le
jour le plus talentueux c'est vrai
qu'ils payent quand même cible il a
bientôt vingt ans par un prêtre un de
ses yeux il est encore jeune
une bonne marge de progression oui à
sadiola de la draft
ce sera pas courant de trouver des
joueurs avec cette marge de progression
voilà ce qu'on peut dire oui mais après
sur le sur le fil chez le juge
j'ai quand même quelques doutes mais
elle est web mail s il n'y a pas un
écart peut-être suffisant en terme de
jeu faire de différence de deux façons
de jouer pour que john lors des dix
minutes
voilà pour jane march et qu'il est
français c'est est ce qu'il va pouvoir
jouer progrès c'est quoi ouais c'est ça
olivier est ce que
est-ce que tu as un scénario idéal pour
le soir de la draft scénario idéal bas
difficile à dire vu comme ça moi je
pense que j'aimerais qu'on arrive à un
trade à peu remonter un petit peu dans
la remontée un petit peu dans la draft
va avoir peut-être une fin d'une femme
premier tour pourquoi pas elle est allé
voler un petit pic
pourquoi pas même encore plus on monte
je parvins aller gratter je sais pas
nassira little ou un joueur comme ça ça
j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien voir ça
arrivait alors l'info faut lâcher du
joueur vous lâcher avec des 40 47 60
non non c'est pas avec les pics
uniquement c'est pour ça qu'on parlait
aussi de quelques joueurs sur la
sellette
donc on sait pas voir et quelques jours
dans la balance qui peuvent qui peuvent
peser pour monter dans la draft mais
idéalement je pense que je pense qu'on
va se séparer d'au moins un pic est allé
chercher à les chercher un ailier moi
j'aimerais bien je sais pas si c'est mon
scénario idéal moi j'aimerais bien que
soit un ailier et expérimenté quoi tout
le monde veut vivre pleinement cette
fois il portland golden state sacramento
on nous on te pose une question sur le
chat est ce que tu lâches bob bob pour
le 24 33 et 34 de ta femme de philippe
mois alors à titre personnel je ne lâche
pas bogdanovic parce que parce que tant
que j'ai pas une garantie d'avoir un
second créateurs se sur le banc je n'ai
pas envie de lâcher un joueur comme
bogdanovic et puis c'est un joueur que
j'aime beaucoup personnellement j'ai un
peu de mal à me projeter sur sur un
trade comme celui là est ce que tu
aurais voulu oui s'il n'avait pas mis le
buzzer beater c'est difficile c'est
l'anglais je pense pas mais mais je
pense que c'est intéressant d'arriver à
bricoler un truc comme ça quand de
lâcher un joueur est d'aller chercher
des pics un peu plus haut sur ce cas là
en particulier moi j'ai envie de dire
non parce que c'est le coeur qui parle
mais
le scion c'est vrai c'est vrai est ce
que tu as des questions sur d'autres
prospects ce que notre ami des pistols
et un peu de problèmes avec sa connexion
internet
mais de qui on m'avait parlé alors on
propose dans le chatt franck mason avec
les pics 60 et 40 pour grimper je pense
qu'avec ça antoine tu vas pas me
contredire tu grande pas beaucoup plus
haut que 35 34 genre de choses
ouais et en montant aux 35 34 mois ya un
joueur que j'aime bien dire ce que vous
en pensez c'est un joueur comme si la
wind l'heure sur le poste 3 eh bien on
en a parlé avec notre ami des warriors
juste avant effectivement dylan wind
l'heure c'est un vrai poste 3 c'est un
vrai bon shooteur et c'est un joueur qui
va pas énormément progressé tu sais ce
que tu achètes louis dallaire ce qu'est
ce que c'est une bière et dix jours
comme ça je dis là c'est pas en ce
moment oui j'ai trois ans de fac
inventive mans oui il est une bière et
10 d'ivan engler après défensivement
c'est plus compliqué même si alors par
séquences moi je l' ai vu bouger ses
pieds mais mais oui notamment face au
match face à cette gérante
ils se retrouvaient en switch facettes
jamar entité pas ridicule alors il ya
moins d'espacé en moins de six écoles
billet sur la même chose d'un peu
masquer la misère plus facilement mais
mais dylan wind leur disons que si tu
veux un peu de ce pays singh un gars il
est très bon rebondeur
vous n'avez pas des caisses des bonbons
d'heure 15 ans
bon vendeur dans ma bulle et bagues les
coûts fausses qui a des bons des bombes
des bons réflexes anciens joueurs de
mont blanc après coup qu'il resigne ou
pas ça c'est moi je pense moi j'aimerais
bien lui je donne bien qu'on traque aux
choses parce que ce qui s'est mal à me
rendre de bons services il est c'est un
gars qui est très constant qui apporte
de la défense du rebond ces quelques
petits points en attaque c'est le chant
de deux jours un peu old school un peu
dur qu'on aime bien
ok moi j'aime bien son profil donc si je
peux le confirmer je le conserve
et ben voilà peut-être le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là et merci à
tous les fans des kings sont toujours
très très nombreux à relayer mieux et il
est encore non mais c'est vrai une
grosse une communauté hyperactive et ça
fait plaisir et encore merci sur le chat
donc donc c'était cool de discuter dé la
draf des kings
merci à angoulême bien et prospects du
second tour et puis on vous souhaite le
meilleur
merci à plus c'est à lui rappelé merci
et on accueille un homme qui a eu des
soucis avec sa box
est-ce que vous avez tenté de débrancher
de rebrancher la boxe ouais je crois que
j'ai tout essayé pour accélérer les
choses mais n'a pas fonctionné c'est
seval du compte alors c'est juste
confond les comptes et ses pistes en
france où ses pistons fr et pippen
france sept copains de façon à tabac
contenteraient bien donc il est là donc
on t'entend vraiment comme si tu étais
vraiment sur la pointe de l'ethiopie
quoi mais
bon bah on va tenter de sortir on
comprend quand même ce que tu dis
parle-nous de detroit on en est où delà
de la situation à détroit tout
simplement action contractuelle des uns
et des autres la situation a été trois
actuellement l'audio la super plus ou
moins la même assez paradoxal dans le
sens où on a besoin considérablement de
d'amélioration du roster pour passer ce
cap
savoir jouer et jouer davantage du
terrain à l'est malheureusement derrière
également une situation financière assez
assez bloqué qui qui on va dire entrave
la marge de manoeuvre des dirigeants il
faut savoir que que les pistols son il
me semble on la septième ou huitième
salary cap - en termes de plafond
salarial énormément de contrat qui
prennent de la place presque inutilement
john mayer avec 10 millions gallaway
avec 7 millions ready jackson bon même
si ce n'est pas inutile il touche tout
de même 18 millions ce qui est ce qui
est assez assez beaucoup donc maintenant
et les pistone doivent même si ce n'est
tient 15e choix à la draft doit se
reposer sur sur ce que je vois là parce
qu'en réalité il ya très très peu de
on va dire d'options d'options estivale
pour des 3t et le 15e choix sont partis
presque des seuls 2 des seules cordes à
notre arc c'est donc ce que tu disais tu
es vraiment du coup c'est un peu une
situation similaire à celle de miami ou
de charlotte ses équipes un peu
d'endroits où ils sont en captant août
donc toi tu disais meilleurs joueurs
disponibles quoi vraiment drafté presque
risquer à un joueur avec du haut
potentiel bah moi je suis assez en
bresse et j'ai presque envie de dire que
je change d'avis presque toutes ces
semaines en fait dans le sens où les
pose plusieurs questions est-ce que les
pistons sont dans une situation à
l'heure actuelle où ils ont le temps de
développer un on va dire un diamant brut
où il faut réellement en réalité un
un ou un joueur plutôt qui certes n'a
pas un potentiel un plafond très très
haut mais qui pourrait dès l'année
prochaine
avoir un impact assez assez importants
sur sur le jeu de dés des pistols c'est
vrai que c'est vraiment un vrai dilemme
pour les pour détroit est en réalité là
la réponse qui serait parfaite c'est
avoir un
on va dire un sorte de rapport équilibré
entre eux le potentiel à développer et
un joueur qui puisse impacter ce dès
l'année prochaine
maintenant c'est sûr que c'est ce qu'il
en existe on sait pas surtout que nous a
surtout besoin de des postes 3,1 et
d'après les dirigeants et même
d'apprendre vonn qui a donné quelques
indices interview les pistols voudrait
un ailier plutôt long plutôt grand
plutôt athlétique
donc il est vrai que il faut voir s'il
existe c'est ce profil là dans les
places 13 13 23 quoi donc maintenant ca
ca t3 de choisir de choisir le meilleur
joueur disponible par rapport à nos
besoins
et d'après d'après rob bishop soit news
donc un des décideurs les plus les plus
influents qu'elle donne johnson ou
peut-il johnson comme on le dit johnson
lui c'est le seul prospects de toute la
drache qui a eu droit un workout
individuels avec des 3 hier donc il ne
s'est pas prêté au traditionnel
puisqu'il peut avoir un moment en nba
lui c'est vraiment été un workout
individuelles et les pistols serait
apparemment plutôt tout intéressé par
par le profil de johnson ok qu'elle
donne johnson alors antoine ne
correspond pas forcément à la
description que tu faisais val juste
avant parce que tu parlais d'un ailier
athlétique et l'on qu'elle donne johnson
il est plutôt athletics en plus il n'est
pas forcément très long et surtout pas
très grand pour un poste trois mois je
ça correspondait plus à nassir little
voit pas ça c'est après c'est vrai que
il ya énormément de bruit qui dans le
michigan
notamment pour par rapport à soi cela
serait soi qui
une porteur du nord soit romeo linford
soit nasir little ou keith johnson
généralement ce sont des quatre noms qui
reviennent le plus mais je pense que
depuis 24 heures maintenant qu'est
johnson a vraiment pris la pôle position
puisque le tennis binder general manager
en disons le est saine ce qui a eu sa
première conférence de presse de la
deûle à l'intersaison et entre les nuits
on comprenait que qu'elle de johnson et
elle a un profil assez assez intéressant
pour des 3 me il a quand même donné
d'autres informations pour la draft des
pistols ed stefanski il a dit que ces
dernières semaines ils ont négocié à
plusieurs reprises pour essayer de
monter dans la draft et que c'était une
oeuvre que c'était une option qui du
moins pas une option qui rejetait
totalement contrairement justement au
tri d'awans qu'il a pour le coup c'est
vraiment une chose qui ne veulent pas
descendre dans la draft qui veulent
monter ou garder leur 15e choix et il a
aussi a évidemment comme beaucoup de
spécialistes comme vous etc qui fut
énormément le généralement le bas c'est
une vie austère et qui couvre
parfaitement cette draft et stephen ce
qu'il a dit voilà je pourrais
aujourd'hui vous donner le top 3 de la
draft et après le top 3 tellement ouvert
que on n'arrive pas à anticiper
on a énormément de voilà comme il l'a
dit énormément de brouillon énormément
de situations on a essayé de réfléchir à
toutes les possibilités qu'ils puissent
se dérouler jeudi soir et il a aussi
ajouté que les petits stone qui avait
énorme qu'il y avait énormément de
joueurs qui correspondent aux besoins
des t3 et qui serait d'après lui un bon
fit à détroit donc est ce qu'il y existe
une cible réellement prioritaire pour
détroit je ne sais pas en tout cas il ya
énormément de joueurs pt3 apprécié dans
cette cuvée antoine après tout toutes
ces informations merci beaucoup c'était
hyper complet il manque aussi un peu sur
le post 2 tu me diras detroit mais
visiblement ça vise un poste 3 comment
comment tu vois la complémentarité des
favoris cas cités
valve avec avec griffin et dru monde
mais dès qu'elle donne little j'ai plus
les deux autres kevin porter du noir au
môle encore parce que ce que j'ai
beaucoup vu entendu parler moi sur des 3
c sur l'angle jardin pour ramener du
haendel notamment parce que si ce que
beaucoup estiment qu'ils manquent quand
on va dire cette équipe donc donc voilà
je pense qu'il ya à peu près à les deux
analyses sur trois qui met langford
heure là des trois quilles about là bas
alors que l'idole et qu'elle donne oui
wave mais après on sait pas on sait pas
toujours tout ce qu'on savait on a pas
mal d'infos sur qui a work out à à
detroit mais bon ça peut venir ça peut
venir aujourd'hui ou demain c'est pas
vous voir même fort même je dis c'est
pas le souci du coup du coup moi j'avoue
j'aime bien l'encré ford parce que ce
que on a si j'avais oublié ton prénom
disait c'est qu'ils l'ont faudra
longtemps qu il ya à la fois un un vrai
potentiel chez ford les planètes peuvent
vraiment s'aligner sur le shooter sur le
sur la défense donc il ya un vrai
potentiel et il apporte immédiatement du
hand les unes une variété d'enjeux des
pistols ouais un peu de créations sur
les lignes arrières qui serait pas de
refus
dans le jeu des pistols et nationales
telles j'aime bien aussi même s'il sera
peut-être hors de portée là pour le coup
ce que sa cote monte aussi très très
très fort sur tout ce qui est tout ce
qui est défense il va pouvoir défendre
dur et sur les work out il semble avoir
excessivement bien shooté ce qui n'a pas
trop montrer cette année mais aussi en
vrai sur le chou de ça allait sur la
défense sur l'homme ça allait c'était un
peu tout le reste n'est pas bien ouais
mais bon en rouge
il a rassuré quand même pas mal sur les
workouts et il sait c'est un instant à
un top prospects à la main il était
était cinquième dans l'immeuble kraft en
début d'année donc il ya un vrai
potentiel et me dit on il peut apporter
un supplément défensif parce que gainey
par exemple sur deux c'est pas non plus
un défenseur de l'année contre
absolument va le tu nous a parlé d'un
poste 3 parce que le l'avenir c'est
qu'est nardo post 2 à detroit est-ce que
c'est l'avenir ça je ne sais pas en tout
cas c'est sûr que c'est clairement le
fait partie des joueurs cette faible ces
faibles lignes extérieures
le joueur le plus talentueux au moins
largement même devant randy jackson un
bout d'un moment faut qu'il faut avouer
que kenan ni pour ma part je n'ai pas
été forcément forcément surpris par le
très bon apport rapide de détroit parce
que j'ai un j'ai montré mon ami qui
s'occupe du comte de duke fr d'ailleurs
je suis pas son petit bonjour à max qui
nous avez vous avez déjà bien vient se
ficher speech est tous à toutes ces
compétences et c'est parce qu'il est
aussi fan des pistols donc je savais à
quoi m'attendre suis vraiment pas déçu
maintenant au bout d'un moment voilà
c'est la troisième saison
il a entre guillemets là le paradoxe du
coulage est plutôt la chance d'avoir des
de jouer dans une équipe aussi faible
sur les extérieurs et bien que dwan qui
commença à le responsabiliser on a vu
qu'on était capable de démonter par
moments à 20 22 points assez facilement
quand il a le ballon et quand il prend
confiance dans son sweat tequila qui
supprime cette peur de shooter luc
hennart 2
vraiment s'inscrire comme le futur
arrière de détroit et c'est pour ça que
pour ma part et d'ailleurs c'est
vraiment plus ou moins l'idée dès que
les dirigeants post croit parce que
voilà sur le poste 2 il ya lutte énarque
qui devrait normalement être titulaire
s'il ne sait s'il n'est pas échangé cet
été lors ce gars là où est toujours son
contrat et malgré tout on a quand même
pas mal de petits postes de à développer
comme khairi thomass qui n'a pas
beaucoup joué lors de sa première saison
à défaut opposé plus tôt à bruce brand
qui lui a beaucoup beaucoup jouer qui
également post 2 qui a montré qu'elle
était titulaire à 56 reprises et qui en
plus de sa eu un impact on défend ça
c'est assez intéressant et on a toujours
aussi mickey yuke lhc ne s'est jamais
prononcée la très bonne vanne d'antoine
sur le site qui a muse l'irex au nom de
famille mais mais mais voilà et aussi
voilà michaël youn quincaillerie thomas
ce week-end à hossegor des postes de
même si en dehors de luc hennart ne
s'est pas forcément la joie de vivre
par rapport au poste 3 comme on peut le
voir notamment sur voilà sur le sur le
screen si on laisse ce brusque brand au
poste 2 en gros il n'ya que ou presque
mixez-les yoox bien occupe arménien que
les deux robinson motion n'a pas
beaucoup joué ce qui va être que les
dirigeants vont activer les ati motion
hans est loin d'être sûr ce qui fait
qu'à l'heure actuelle il ya vraiment
pour le coût zéro est liée à des trois
réel et donc tu penses que même avec le
45 qui vont essayer aussi de draft et un
poste 3 qui éventuellement pourraient
faire backup
bah justement moi j'étais en train de
finaliser justement bas avec toujours
avec votre collaboration
demain un article sur les second tour
pour mon site est en effet regardez il
ya pas mal de postes 3 j'ai l'impression
d'un 45 plus intéressant après bon les
mauves draft au deuxième tour c'est
toujours un peu hasardeux on s'était
fixé la barre à se prononcer mais il me
semble que moi j'ai bien aimé notamment
un profil qui vient l'impression
correspond si on n'arrive pas à voir cet
ailier
au grand poujeaux athlétique plus tôt
avec une grosse envergure j'ai
l'impression que vous me disent s'ils me
trompe admiral schofield ça il me semble
que louise pourrait peut-être un joueur
intéressant pour t3 en 45
sinon il ya aussi louis king et si les
étoiles sont alignées cameron unchained
mais bon ça je crois pas une seule
seconde je pense que cameron fera partie
avancée comme qui est ce que vous avez
workout darius base l'aise pareil ça
sera parti avant sur le chat on demande
antoine est ce que c'est nickel
alexander walker c'est pas une bonne
idée
j'ai vu je les ai vus j'ai vu cité parmi
les les gens qui aimait bien les pistols
ouais pareil on l'a prédit jackson
disait on en a déjà parlé ce soir mais
effectivement c'est pas une pour l'après
après ouais ouais ouais je pense que
c'est un choix peut-être pas voir là
prêt mais plus le complément est ce
qu'il peut il peut il peut aussi jouer
postes 2 et il est très bon en quatre
shoots
ouais il ya déjà beaucoup de postes de
comme le disait veulent loi mais bon il
peut apporter
ça permet de jouer différemment si
d'avoir d'avoir un poste 2 qui est
capable de porter le ballon est capable
de voilà de d'offrir deux frères un peu
de jeu un peu différent comme comme le
copain jim boeheim aime bien faire et à
voter au deuxième tour
admira schofield donc on rappelle qu'il
est né dans la même maternité que les
princes harry et william
ça va nous faire toute l'année ce truc
schofield je suis pas vraiment fan non
non je suis pas vraiment fan je vois pas
ce qui pourrait apporter vraiment de
plus que par les drones à son poste 3
sachant que je vois la braise gros noeud
si tu joues titre je suis pas sûr que ça
non plus tonton options ça soit une
option numéro un
défend quoi ce qu'ils admirent albouy
cocteau pas sûr qu'ils défendent sur les
postes extérieurs
oui ces problèmes à deux possibles dont
on sait pas trop ce et c'est toujours
difficile à définir les joueurs comme ça
pas bon val
oui ton scénario idéal pour jeudi et
après ce sera le tour des nets aller au
premier tour qu'elle donne johnson ouais
et au second louis king allez allez
vendu ces bandits c'est une machine en
add des noms qui reviennent allée louis
king les démineurs et il ya la passion
la façon tu sais pourquoi parce que tout
le monde aime les ailiers quand même pas
que c'est pas faux aujourd'hui dans la
nba le monde aime les zones y est donc
donc c'est logique merci beaucoup val
d'avoir aidé ou malgré ta connection
chancelante
tu es tu t'es fait pas mal chambré sur
le chat je te laisserais répondre
comment l'alcool notamment
voilà ça va répondre merci beaucoup et
on accueille les nets et c'est quentin
il me semble j'ai plus tous les prénoms
devant moi mais qu'elle est là avec nous
salue quand un salut les gars
comment vont les nets parlez nous coûte
ça va pas trop mal
ces personnes nous attendait là où on a
fini en fin de saison donc on ne peut
pas dire que qu'on a vécu une grosse
galère on s'attend à un été plus que que
chaud parce que je sais pas si vous avez
vu un peu toutes les rumeurs mais
apparemment caillard binya aujourd'hui
snober les celtics et s'apprête à venir
chez nous bon c'est pas ce qui me
réjouit le plus moi personnellement et
mais en tout cas les nets s'apprête
apparemment a changé de dimension cet
été alors je sais pas s'il sera un
impact sur la draft on aura l'occasion
de revenir là dessus mais en tout cas l
actu l'actuel chaude l'actu chaude
exactement qu'est ce que tu as pensé du
trade
du pic 17h17 c'est ça ouais c'est le 17
et le pic de l'année prochaine écoute ce
moi je suis un peu je m'attendais à ce
qu'on achète un pic parce que fallait se
débarrasser du contrat dalaï crabe on en
avait parlé justement je vois que vous
l'avez affiche à l'écran dans ce que
vous nous aviez demandé de préparer ya
quelques temps ouais c'était un des
objectifs de sean marks presque bas de
18 millions pour un joueur qui n'est pas
titulaire c'est énorme dans une barre
d'un salary cap
moi je pensais qu'on lâcherait lepic 27
maintenant si on a été enfin je pense
que si sean marks ça a bougé si tôt et
qu'il a bougé de deux pics de premier
tour dont le 17 c'est qu'il avait des
certitudes pour cet été donc bon depuis
qu'il est là je lui fais totalement
confiance
donc je pense que c'est un mal pour un
bien en fait il fallait se faire
violence pour pouvoir se libérer de
l'année de kénitra d'amérique rabon l'a
fait ok et on va tu sais quoi on va
demander l'avis aux chefs
parce qu'en fait il ya le chef qui est
venu nous rendre visite
vraiment une façon de me présenter
bah si c'est toi le chef jb est ce que
tu veux jb de poster dunk
jb poster dunk @ poster dunk c'est le
chef
comment vaincu super il doit savoir chef
on peut on peut en profiter pour
rediriger vers votre superbe podcast qui
avait il y avait de gaver de l'invité de
marque
il ya des biens réels à l'acd française
de la loose effectivement pour la
rétrospective de la saison et demie qui
s'est terminée puisque c'était plutôt
pas mal pour brooklyn cette saison mais
une façon de bien terminer la saison nba
avec le titre de toronto le transfert
d'anthony les lis énormément d'actualité
alors ton avis sur le les net's sur sur
déjà ce petit trade du 17 pour se
débarrasser du contrat d'haleine crabe
et puis sur la rumeur car irving qui
enfle qui devient presque une certitude
si on écoute si on écoute quand on pas
une certitude mais en tout cas qui qui
enfle
quel est ton avis là dessus est ce que
c'est une bonne idée pourtant déjà n'y a
jamais de certitudes avec irene c'est la
première chose
les fans des celtics étaient persuadés
qu'ils resteraient après ses
déclarations de début de saison c'est
franchement bien joué puisque
puisqu'elle aime crabes
son contrat était quasi un beau diable
mais ça a été fait a été fait au bon
moment je pense les nets sont dans une
situation qui est à la fois ultra
intéressante puisque ils sont maîtres de
leur pic et de leur futur pour la
première fois depuis six ans et en plus
ils prennent les choses en main et
continue des bérets de l'espace
franchement les choses qui sont faites
sont faites d'un bon sens j'ai aucune
certitude ni pour quérir ligne
d'ailleurs ni pour le long terme
d'audience vélo russell puisque est ce
que le potentiel de ce soir a été
atteint cette saison
est-ce que les nets ne considère pas
justement qu'ils sont qui l'ont porté le
voir plus haut possible
est-ce qu'il va pas finir par est née
sur orbite ou dans l'avion ça aussi
c'est une grosse question je ne connais
pas la vie de quentin et de l'équipe de
brooklyn est fermé l'incertitude et net
c'est quand même là
il ya eu un excellent travail de fait et
le bouger allen cram l'envoyer comme ça
en géorgie c'est bien joué pour ça mais
mais c'est encore très incertain
c'est encore très incertain quentin
d'accord avec ça pour toi ça va aussi
dépendre de ça parce que les nets vont
faire le soir de la draft le destin de
kairi en ligne bah du coup alors
j'entends pas ce que dit jb alors je
suis un peu embêté du coup parce que
c'est difficile pour moi de rebondir sur
ce qu'il a dit est ce qu'on peut me
faire un résumé à aulas là je vais me
risquer mais il a dit qu'en gros il
était il était tout à fait heureux et
satisfaits et qui pensaient que c'était
une bonne idée de libérer du cap par par
le trade d'haleine crabes que voilà les
choses prenaient forme et que le
franchise prenait son destin en main
quoi et après pour khairi il a dit qu'il
y avait beaucoup d'incertitude et dois
je lis pas forcément prononcer ce que
c'est une bonne est ce que c'est une
mauvaise idée voulait aussi un peux
avoir ton avis commençait à nous dire
tout à l'heure que tu étais pas
forcément fan de l'idée de de kairi
enfin de se débarrasser de russell ou en
tout cas de faire venir karim est même
question c'était votre draft votre été
ça va tourner autour de ça toute façon
oui totalement bas alors moi c'est vrai
que je me suis beaucoup beaucoup avancé
sur les réseaux sociaux comme quoi
j'étais plutôt je faisais plutôt partie
de ceux qui voulaient garder dit angelo
russell pour plusieurs raisons et pour
moi il sort de sa sa meilleure saison en
carrière il a 23 ans est un joueur qui
peut que progresser
c'est aussi un peu le visage du
renouveau des nets donc via la
reconstruction de l'aréna qu'une somme
de ça fait trois ans on commence juste à
relever la tête et en fait ce qui me
fait un peu peur c'est que on voudrait
passer directement enfin retourner dans
le star-system nba alors effectivement
il ya moins de risques avec kyle herring
avec paul pierce et kevin garnett
mais j'ai l'impression qu'on va
peut-être à payer sauter une étape
on vouloir aller trop vite moi je suis
voilà je suis plutôt de ceux qui
voudraient garder dit angelo russell
après j'ai eu et j'ai eu cette semaine
de trois contacts aux états unis qui
m'ont plutôt expliqué que karine serait
la porte d'entrée pour une autre star et
qui le feront office aurait peur de pas
pouvoir attirer une star en gardant donc
c'est un peu c'est un peu en fait le je
pense qu'ils ont un peu le cul entre
deux chaises ou patiemment l'expression
etc ça peut-être qu'ils créent dans
certitudes en fait et qui c'est pour moi
le la décision d'ailleurs on va le
savoir je pense relativement vite parce
que la presse gm si c'est dans quinze
jours donc de savoir si oui ou non ils
donnent une croix des feuilles nauphary
dancefloor aux seuls et ça va déterminer
pas mal de choses pour cet été
ok que le doigt je réponds pardon et
puis tu feras la traduction que j'ai
l'impression que l'on parle
effectivement d'un seul côté le
dirigeant au sein d'un point de vue
complètement objectif et actuel de
retour sur investissement c'est
peut-être le moment pour commander en
anglais c'est là y vendre à bon prix
pour recel
et effectivement le moulin gratte
suggère que il ya la place pour deux
personnes offert bonheur de personnes
cet été donc why not et puis voilà notre
temps que le coup a indiqué qu'une duran
duran est blessé c'est quand un ton
toujours pas ce que dit jb toujours pas
malheur ou pas alors il dit il c'était
le business man jb qui carnet et qui
disait est ce que c'est pas le est-ce
que là en gros la cote de diane jane
russell est ce qu'elle sera un jour plus
haute que celle ci c'est jusqu'à l'est
actuellement et donc est-ce que c'est
pas le moment finalement de vendra au
prix me disais c'est leipp ce qu'il est
un peu bilingue
le problème c'est qu'en fait on va pas
le vendre il est free agent mise à part
mise à part via un sign and trade âme et
évite de lui donner trop d'argent en
comptera aussi a par contre oui oui la
seule solution en fait ça reviendrait à
le laisser partir libre
en lui ayant offert une bonne cote si on
peut parler comme ça et en tournant la
page assez rapidement après où
effectivement les deux scénarios à mon
avis ce s'entendent
je sais que c'est un sujet qui divise
beaucoup auprès des fans qui alors c'est
la culture de l'instant comme dirait
certains qui dans steam si beaucoup les
lettres s'adjuger leur au sol depuis
quelques mois voilà moi j'ai mon avis
après effectivement khayarine tout seul
ça ne ça me plaît pas karine plus une
autre star je sais pas qui qui viendrait
ça parle de de faim ou la volonté
apparemment de kairi ça serait de venir
avec l'idée émane de radio web
maintenant il vient de se blesser alors
ça veut dire faire l'impasse entre
guillemets la mini impasse sur la saison
prochaine au kawa il me c'est quasiment
sûr qu'il jugera pas il reste 10 minutes
leur tombe bien ça laisse bon à voir
voilà donc donc avoir alors parlons de
la draft qu'on a quand même là pour ça
allons-y 27 et 31 chez vous 27 et 31
qu'est-ce que tu quel est ton ton envie
et qu'est ce qui se murmure du côté de
brooklyn puisque tu te tient évidemment
au courant des déchets otages et ben
écoute comme comment dernier déjà c'est
très opaque
c'est très opaque il ya très peu d'infos
qui sortent
la tendance serait si là encore
disponible mais je vois chez vous qui d
un poil plus haut à l'arrivée de luca
sam and each voilà qui en fait qui colle
parfaitement au profil qu'ont été drafté
par les nets ces deux dernières années
face à athlétiquement parlant il a des
airs de corps ou tce mouzat au niveau de
la taille et de l'envié un lion il ya un
physique est pas tout à fait une bière
et 10 voire même pas du tout après des
profils de joueurs un peu différent mais
c'est le le profil qui se détachent en
tout 4 beaucoup de gens dans les
insiders des nex pense que c'est le
joueur qui fuit très le mieux moi mon
envie elle se dirige plutôt vers un big
men et je sais qu'on en a on en a un
petit peu parlé sur les réseaux sociaux
ce qu'on l'a choisi sur la mode draft
les fers de qi basket c'est bruno
fernando que je trouve hyper intéressant
et qui viendrait apporter un peu de
taille dans la raquette des led alors
jarrett allèles après je pense que vous
en pensez de ce mec là moi j'ai
l'impression que le profil peut
cartonner en janvier alors plusieurs
choses
évidemment les destins de on imagine
deux êtres davis jared dudley démarrer
carole ça va un peu dépendre de ce qui
se passe sur la free agency tus est
confirmée et donc lantoine peut-être
répondre sur sam and each déjà puisque
le corps pas forcément une bière et 10 c
à nuancer avec ce qui s'est passé au nba
combined et puis répond sur fernando qui
ont fait un coucou à à benne qui n'est
pas là ce soir mais qui est fan du gros
bruno ont été durs tu me fais parler sur
deux joueurs que j'apprécie moyennement
mais on peut pas parler tout le temps
des gens quand même bien ouais non ça
sera un c'est très rapide
[Rires]
je pense que de toute façon les ça
correspond on va dire aux besoins des
nets parce que les besoins sont comme
pour moi sur le roster sur les postes 3
4 5 sur le fait que kiki qu'il faut
aussi un peu de shooting sur ces
postes-là et que sam and each et ben et
fernando apporte tous les deux ça donc
donc c'est intéressant pour cette équipe
je pense
le piqué le 27 mois ils ont 27 et 31
donc c'est vraiment rapproché 1,2731
effectivement ça dépend ce que tu veux
faire je suis pas sûr que ça m'a
nietzsche puisse céder très directement
tout de suite
pour voilà pour faire progresser
l'équipe
clairement j'ai un doute
oui peut-être peut-être dans la
troisième enfin en 10e 10e et 11e au
maintien comme ça mais et fernando shr
un peu plus sûres je pense parce qu'il
ya vraiment du il ya vraiment un trou
davis il est fréquent que c'est ça les
agents et la dernière rumeur ça serait
certaines équipes voyant lutte potentiel
de faire le jeu le type de joueur sur
lequel on pouvait s'engager sur
plusieurs années donc donc
potentiellement certaines équipes
pourrait lui donner des contrats longs
on parle de trois ans alors que les led
c'est sont bloquées du fait qu'ils n'ont
signé qu'un an l'an dernier ils ont pas
l'air libr de rise et du coup le contrat
proposé serait moins alléchant que ce
qu'on peut lui mettre ailleurs ce qui
vient compliquer le dossier de davis qui
lui a clamé déjà depuis plusieurs mois
que son envie première serait de rester
du coup personnellement je pense que
j'irai chercher des blues fernando
plutôt parce qu'il j'aime beaucoup la
complémentarité qui pourrait apporter
avec turenne
ouais un côté d'un côté de la viande de
l'autre de l'os c'est ça du coup on est
d'accord comprenons fernando est
beaucoup plus étoffé physiquement que
jared allen en lounge à natal elle lui
subi des points un peu l'impact vous
nous fermons doute pour toi est capable
de répondre immédiatement nba ah oui il
l'a il a la puissance c'est sûr c'est
pas non plus le défenseur de l'année moi
j'aime pas trop trop sa défense en non
non non mais quand il s'agit d'encaisser
le contact il et il est plutôt présent
il peut mais après pour masser les c'est
plus un joueur un peu situationnelle
fernando mais qui peut rendre pendant de
longues années des services quoi voilà
septies je le vois pas en tant que de
toute façon que ce soit clair sound
resteront dehors de mj barrette et zain
williamson je vois pas de starter des
one dans cette draft
mais fernando je suis pas sûr que son
starter non plus dans une dans une
équipe de play off
ça sera jamais mais je pense ça peut
être un bon bac à pois mais en 27 avoir
un bon back up
je sais que vous aviez été hyper
élogieux sur le cac kabengele dans un
nouveau podcast et je vois dans votre
motif qu'il est il est plutôt alors il y
en a qui le voit très haut
aux alentours de 20 mais il ya aussi
qu'ils voient sur les places qui
pourraient être les nôtres c'est un
profil que si tu veux comparer un peu à
ces une grave de postes 4 1 au poste 4
qui sont un peu plus haut je pense
notamment à grant williams par exemple
parce que c'est un profil qui reste
intéressant kabengele c'est plus 1,5 à
ce qu'il annonce et quatre chez vous du
coup son oreille oui il faudrait pourra
peut-être joué quatre par séquences mais
il ya quand même plus la mobilité d'un
5e d'un 4 choquerait pas bleu voir avec
4 ouais bon cela dit la différence avec
les autres grands disons c'est c'est le
shoot principalement c'est vraiment la
grosse différence c'est que c'est le
serment de shoot à 3 c'est ça de
fernando shoot un petit peu à 3 mais
c'est balbutiant alors que kabengele à
prenez un bon volume de tirs à trois
points cette année et il les mettait
quoi et ça c'est un joueur qui revient
de blessure c'est ça ben on est d'accord
antoine chaînas non non je crois pas du
tout et il a des nerfs du bizarre mais
j'ai dû confondre avec un autre joueur
dont vous avez parlé c'est peut-être au
kéké qui avait eu bien sûr c'est que
j'ai la peau de caste vous parler des
deux de mémoire et vu que les débits
élevés mais il revient pas d'ailleurs il
est blessé actuellement d'accord avec
journée c'est bien et les ligaments du
genou voilà est-ce que tu as une autre
question rapide on a pris un petit peu
de retard mais c'est pour la bonne cause
hatz au bas du cou grise lice puisque
les thunder est pas la pression et ben
très rapidement alors pour laisser la
main à mon collègue de mémoire il ya un
petit produit local qui se trimballe
dans les modes draft c'est le petit
chameau réponse et c'est un peu bas
enfin c'est un peu bas par rapport à nos
pics
maintenant est ce que c'est un joueur
qui pourrait venir aider ce qu'on sait
que il ya la team option de deux
chapelles napier qui pourrait ne pas
être gardés pour libérer du cap et
potentiellement c'est un petit meneur
cas l'air intéressant et j'aimerais bien
votre avis sur ce profil là alors cham
oripeaux nous on en a parlé on a parlé
quand aujourd'hui hier on se perd on en
a pas on est alors tout à l'heure
c'était et bien c'est un meneur qui fait
j'ai plus sa taille mais jour en 4 entre
1 88 et 1 92 un peu d'eux il a une
longueur correct il est il est plutôt
correct en défense en plus ça sera
jamais un le défenseur de l'année comme
d'iran tonnes et on attaque bien il a
été irrégulier parce qu'il avait il
avait pas mal de choses a créé cette
année et c'est ce qui fait quand toi ne
l'aiment pas trop c'est qu'il a été
c'est vraiment vraiment irrégulier au
niveau de ses choix et même au niveau du
tir il ya des matches où il explosait où
il m'était 35 points d'autres où il
explose et dans l'autre sens donc c'est
un petit peu compliqué et après c'est
plutôt moi je trouve un bon passeur
dans l'ensemble c'est pas le super
créateurs mais je veux dire pour un
meneur backup ça peut ça peut faire le
taf d'autant plus comme tu dis que c'est
un produit local
donc ouais c'est ça qui me plaît en fait
c'est le fait que hbo qui souhaitent
schengen c'est que potentiellement le
garder pas loin et puis le développer
kenya clinton a fait un super travail
avec tous et voir ce depuis trois ans
dit qu'il pourrait en profiter en fait
dès qu'il a le bien le potentiel du mec
qui met des cartons à une bille et de
temps en temps
donc voilà bon eh bah écoute
pourquoi pas des cartons c'est peut-être
un peu ambitieux des cartons enfin les
petits cartons voilà des cartonnettes
mais non on a déjà parlé tout à l'heure
et je crois que antoine a forcément
d'autres choses à ajouter sur son avis à
part à part si je me trompe ou et non
voilà merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous merci les gars vous la prochaine
c'est très sympa c'est les nets c'était
quentin et on a beaucoup de respect pour
le boulot abattu sur le compte twitter
des nets ce qui est qui est vraiment de
qualité
on a quelques larmes
bravo c'est un bravo de du chef gilles
beck tentante
bravo et bravo voilà voilà
une voix une voix une voix grave on
descend d'un octave etienne et là
bonjour tout le monde
un autant chalut notre des chefs
messieurs vous allez pouvoir qu'on soit
des grizzlies ce soit du thunder dans
l'ordre normalement c'était le thunder
mai mais vu qu'on adore connexion avec
sa merci le thunder et j'aime beaucoup
c'est un peu oui c'est un peu
d'entraînement ils sont tous les deux là
tommy et pour le thunder
j'ai pas ton prénom solal thomis et pour
l'église et pour le pur plowman pour le
thunder bay but je l'entends pas vous
l'entendez vous son petit nom ça a l'air
d'être sardou oui c'est marqué sardou
mais alors est-ce que c'est à mathieu
non mais est-ce que vous à c'est mathieu
tu es tu là est-ce que belge sa coupe
parfois c'est bizarre vous les avez
préféré du vous l'aimez pas entendu à
risque ce n'est pas un essai au
mathieu est ce que ça dérange tu nous
fait signe à un coût pour wii de coûts
pour nombre est ce que ça te dérange
c'est une commence par tommy le temps
que tu arrêtes tes problèmes techniques
non ça ne dérange pas merci à cassen que
janssen ou troll en plus là et oui alors
que alors que franchement je suis allé
chercher poster dunk s'est pas beaucoup
mieux
il faut venir chez officielle de ses
fils elle sait un peu plus ce programme
etienne c'était c'est quoi le dernier
épisode de ficelles avant qu'on commence
c'est sûr alors le dernier épisode
c'était c'était il ya longtemps c'était
pendant les playoffs
donc c'était au tout début des play off
au juste au moment des cars donc
ça remonte un petit peu il faudrait
qu'on le prochain je pense ça sera pour
analyser les finales mais moi on m'a dit
qu'il fallait que je vienne parce qu'on
parlait de beaucoup de jeunes et qu'on
parlait d'une ligue super importante et
qui avait plein de développer parler de
la jeep élite
absolument mais tu vas pouvoir donner
ton avis sur la situation des grises
lisez donc tommy qui est là bonjour
tommy comment vas tu sers gâteau ça va
très bien et vous bon on peut ce pas
trop mal pas trop mal antoine est à son
deuxième saucisson alan moi je crois non
mais j'ai même pas comment c'est être
con apéro là à bon ya pas la petite
bière on a pris du retard à bassila
bercy mais c'est pas la peur au sein
c'est celui où je rigole je me parle
août et grizzly ce qu'est ce qui va se
passer cet été et comment envisager ce
choix numéro deux un peu un peu de
tomber du ciel
je tenais à dire que je suis très
content de cette présente de la loterie
après lyon l'année dernière on perd deux
places et lormont mangane 6 donc
forcément pas ce qu'est ce que tu es
pelican bay ferries les affaires alors
vas-y pape parle nous de cette
intersaison qui s'annonce vous avez
quand même pas mal de joueurs sous
contrat on voit ça sur sur live là les
seules free à john finalement c'est un
peu des joueurs un peu lointain dans la
rotation
qu'est ce que vous allez faire de tout
ce beau monde à niveau free a jackal
valanciunas et de leur ait qui sont tous
les deux pour l'instant c'est pas trop
s'ils vont rester souvent de partir en
avalant jean haas qui a décliné son
option mais peut-être apparemment pour
négocier sur plus long terme tandis
qu'on a ride john wright qui lui free
agent de mai restrictive donc on sait
pas encore si on va réussir à le garder
donc cette dépit de questions
mais la plus grosse problématique entre
guillemets c'est celle de mâconnais et
donc la relève s'apprête à tourner une
page donc forcément avec jam au round
apparemment c'est le choix qui est le
plus évident celle que celui qui est
qu'on entend un peu partout et donc
voilà un peu la situation de pour
l'instant est ce que pour toi c'est
vraiment la bonne idée de
c'est partir maicon laisse que c'est ce
qui va vraiment est-ce que sa valeur est
haute et après on posera la question à
jbeniana c'est intéressant d'essayer de
juger de jauger de la valeur de mike
conway
il reste sur une saison quand même sa
meilleure saison en carrière quoi pour
l'instant sa valeur je pense qu'elle
n'est pas trop mal même s'il va rester
qu'un an de contrat derrière et je pense
que c'est l'heure de peut-être tourner
la page mais il faut pas non plus se
précipiter parce qu'on peut pour
l'instant il ya différentes rumeurs qui
vont du jazz ne faut pas que c'était
n'importe quelle offre on a pu
l'imaginer
on a pu l'entendre qu'est-ce que tu
acceptes près toi contre maicon mais
qu'est ce qui ce qui serait capable
d'aider des futurs choix de draft
l'objectif du front-office soit c'est
différent ça c'est donc saisir soit des
jeunes qui peuvent progresser soit des
pics de draft qui pourrait être pour
l'avenir quoi
ça a coupé à l'eau
orphée pardon jeudi pour je sais pas
pourquoi sa coupe et kiki qui est là qui
n'est pas là je voulais relancer etienne
sur le sur la situation de mecs comme le
lait sur sa cote est présent christelle
soit soit encore de retour
ficelle n'est pas le retour jb alors
écoute d'accord comme ils du coup sûr
sur ma vie je ne suis pas certain que la
sélection de jamhour haine tu veux dire
du coup que l'on sépare de maicon est
alors la logique voudrait que oui comme
il soit sur le départ mais un an de dire
de tutorial colis moraine pourrait
pourrait bien fonctionner déjà maurenn
tu apportera énormément de vitesse à une
équipe des grévistes qui en a qui en a
bien besoin et michael et pourrait pour
l épauler à après sa cote à mon avis il
faut effectivement le transfert est
maintenant ou en tout cas cet été
pendant le mois de juillet puisque tu
peux espérer y attacher un contrat je
veux même pas vous dire lequel vous
savez très bien auquel je pense tu peux
espérer attaché maicon li na à quelqu'un
d'autre et puis l'envoyer effectivement
plutôt plutôt à l'est non seulement pour
lui faire plaisir mais aussi pour éviter
de retourner sur lui mais je pense que
les grizzlies ce2 effectivement doivent
s'en séparer soit pendant la loterie
soit soit juste après début juillet
parce que parce que sa cote est au plus
haut et en plus ça permettrait de
libérer un contrat dès que quoi mais
encore une fois je ne pense pas que les
deux soient incompatibles
si tu arrives à te débarrasser de
michael bay qui est quand même à 32
millions l'année prochaine c'est pas mal
quand même
après il ya il se plaît pas allez vous
parlez plutôt de bons salaires vie
meilleure je parlais plus du salaire
mais après effectivement il a 31 ans
donc il est encore
il ya encore quelques années devant il a
quand même une valeur sûre sur le marché
aujourd'hui
c'est sûr que pour une fille se dégager
32 millions dans le cap ça ferait du
bien ce qui est intéressant sur la
situation du fait qu'il ait beaucoup de
joueurs sous contrat mais la trouvaille
de caboclo et la renaissance de kaboul
où c'est intéressant
anderson et jackson junior c'est quand
même assez assez chouette de les
développer de les travailler
tommy a raison sur banane shauna ce qui
je pense va vouloir sécuriser un peu à
la leur ford en parallèle d'ailleurs à
boston n'est pas vouloir sécuriser à
long terme parce que c'est la sécurité
c'est ce que des joueurs cherchent de
plus en plus donc la situation a même si
ce n'est pas mauvaise du tout et qu'on
vise plutôt de moyen terme c'est pas
vraiment long terme d'ailleurs c'est un
peu entre eux deux 13 la loterie
accélérer le processus en fait on
exactement
du coup la situation très intéressante
pour pour memphis qui en plus avec un
top 2 défi d'aider second choix
mais avec un top 2 peut vraiment faire
la différence sur le chat on nous
propose collé contre maubeuge bat et le
pit 17 plus d'autres pics
cbg 26,69 non paris web et patrimoine
s'est pas déclenché lorsque movember l'a
pas trop vu cette année mais on imagine
qu'ils peuvent encore progresser
21 l'autre hic c'est donc moi je vais
voir quand même un assez bon plafond
pourquoi pas un pic 17 sur une grave
aussi faible dans la vie de maximiser
tout premier tour a reconnu et même si
c'est qu'un an
ça me parait cette année donc les
italiens clément qui dit sur le chat que
finalement entre gros salaires
l'historique des blessures et l'âge
commence à être avancé de maicon mais il
faut pas en attendre monts et merveilles
non plus surtout le conte rock qui
bloque un peu les offres quoi oui c'est
du moins des équipes comme un bon il ya
toujours preneurs de gros contrats
surtout à l'est entre deux équipes trash
avec des mecs qui sont prêts à prendre
les 32 millions tant que ça leur a pas
d'autres et je pense que honnêtement tu
peux trouver un peu mieux que ben badi
scène alors tommy quand même est ce
qu'il te plaît jam orange imagine que tu
t'es quand même renseigné depuis le
temps qu'on en parle celle aux mines
basses elles n'ont qu'à le plus sûr
qu'il peut sortir donc forcément c'est
bien renseigner vos podcasts et donc
c'est vraiment un joueur qui semble
intéressant parce que pour prendre la
relève
c'est un style un peu différent de
maicon et c'est beaucoup plus dans les
qualités athlétiques dans l'énergie et
moi j'avais une question à vous poser
c'est par rapport aux qualités de
gestionnaire on s'est connu était
presque parfait ce niveau là est ce que
j'aime auront été plus quelqu'un qui a
plus tendance à foncer dans le tas ou
bien il est capable aussi de gérer un
tempo déjà un match sont les temps forts
et les temps faibles
antoine c'est des trucs qui arrive
souvent très tard chez les meilleures
preuves conlan m
oui preuve connaît ou même tony parker
et a mis du temps à bien gérer le tempo
et cédera donc ou pas faut pas en
attendre non plus trop tout de suite de
drames que je pense sait rien de lui
mettre trop la pression et et je suis
d'accord il faut qu' il faut enfin moi
perso je suis dans le staff de memphis
je garde je garde le le cône l'est
jusqu'à jusqu'au all star break quoi
je le fais je me suis fait pendant six
mois
histoire que que le copain jam ou rennes
c'est quand même ils apprennent de 3 2 3
2 3 trucs parce que lille encore des
choses à apprendre et je m'en sépare
avant que avant qu'il soit frais de
jambes parce que je vois là est-ce qu'il
va revenir il ya quand même des doutes
je pense qu'à partir d'un certain âge
leur origine bien joué pour un titre nba
ça voudrait pas tout de suite à memphis
donc
donc je pense qu' il vaut mieux s'en
séparer pour reconstruire à plus
durablement ensuite oui depuis quatre
jours et qu'ils étaient coupées pour
soues à la parade il a les soirs de
match n'a suivi ça de très près pendant
ces playoffs
et pour finir sur le profil de jam
arendt ça reste un des excellents
passeur de cette grave même si la prise
de décisions allaient et venaient alors
c'est pas hautement du tempo mais je
veux dire il sait faire jouer les autres
cette année c'est un distributeur pour
l'instant c'est par là surtout qu'il
était mal entouré et mal entouré
les mots sont forts comme tu dis des
doigts en en mi majeur dans une équipe
où il y avait il y avait un arrière
d'assez bonne qualité il y avait un
grand qui avait pas dément dégueu
dégueulasse mais en bleu c'est
effectivement le personnel c'est pas
celui qu'il aura à ses côtés à memphis
c'est sûr c'est un côté des amateurs de
l'autre des professionnels est aussi un
problème de rapport enfin le gros point
noir que vous avez c'est les perdre oui
parce que ça peut être rédhibitoire
bah on n'aime jamais les joueurs qui
perdent trop de ballons séparé d'être
évident dit comme ça mais mal après
malgré ces pertes de balle par match il
il avait un ratio à 6 turnovers
quasiment m2
6 par match et comme on l'a dit juste
avant il n'y avait pas énormément de
gens avec lui qui gérait la tacc donc au
bout d'un moment le gars il avait la
balle tout le temps dans les mains
pendant quasiment 40 minutes vraiment
constamment ils s'exposent quoi il y en
avait un qui pouvaient spots up un peu
et le poste 3 qui pouvaient en donne un
minimum mais au final le rendent si la
caisse quand on est toutes les positions
et non une usine
yooz edge personnes tel jeu de 33% c'est
beau normal un peu quoi après la chose
inquiétante sur les balles perdues parce
qu'il ya le volume qui fait quoi
forcément il va en perdre plus mais
c'était peut-être le fait de vouloir
chercher la passe flashy plutôt que la
passe d'efficace et ça il y en avait
quelques unes donc encore une fois c'est
quelque chose qu'ils peuvent qui peut se
gommer assez facilement enfin c'est
facilement qui peut se gommer en tout
cas voilà mais il a il a la capacité de
faire des passes absolument magnifique
et difficile et du fait de ses longs
bras il est plutôt grand pour
randonneurs enfin il ya une tête correct
en meneur et de ses qualités athlétiques
et de haendel il à l'arsenal technique
en tout cas pour évoluer au poste taillé
pas de souci à part le shoot pour
l'instant voilà voilà sur dja maurane je
crois que jb est sur le départ comme
prochaine n'avait les kings il ya 20
minutes bon ça paraît être une décision
complètement con mais et du coup je vous
laisse comme comme lui du coup mais
réputé n'est pas réputé pour faire pour
prendre des décisions intelligentes à
ces régimes et salue jb merci d'être
passé les dix coups pour l'église disons
garde joakim noah ou pas mais en fin de
contrat aussi et puis je pense que il
s'est peut-être montré en valeur dont
peut-être que des comptes des équipes
vont le proposer autre chose que le
minimes aux vétérans quoi on peut pas
lui proposer plus pour l'instant dans
l'état donc c'est compliqué parce que il
n'ya pas tant de cap que ça ouais parce
que sinon on n'a pas de pivot pour
l'instant ça d'enregistrer dans
l'effectif on est vraiment un chèque à
ce niveau là oui donc bon bah du coup
c'est vrai que maurane c'est ce qu'on
annonce depuis le début est ce que pour
toi drafté en meneur que c'était
forcément là c'était obligatoire
c'était une priorité pas obligatoire
mais ce qui m'a paru le plus évident
quoi enfin au niveau des talents
disponibles en plus et au niveau du fid
que ça pourrait représenter
on sait que déjà depuis la deadline
enfin la dernière deadline dont avec
hazard les connais qui était mis sur le
marché
gasoil est parti connaît on s'y
attendait aussi donc l'heure semble
venue donc la salade est le bon moment
comme un meneur et puis après on sait
que dans la nba actuelle l'accès
intérieur extérieur important on a
récupéré déjà l'année dernière
et si on peut avoir une belle
association entre les deux ça peut être
pas mal pour l'avenir
notre chouchou jackson junior vas-y
etienne et je vais je dire en plus de ça
le premier pivot dans votre bloc illégal
m 11e avec avec minnesota donc ça sert à
rien de prendre un joueur qui est
évaluée khiêm ici bas il peut se passer
des choses c'est tu peux trade down the
way mais bon on va passer de 2 à passer
de 2 ans vous êtes forcément une bonne
idée d'autant plus que le top 3 c'est
clairement établie mais tu ce que je
veux dire c'est drafté air djebar est
qu'un post 2 c'est pas forcément la pire
idée du monde quoi non voilà c'est
surtout c'est surtout ça le souci mais
doucement quand même maintenant les et
jeunes en tout cas les prospects se
permettent de faire des de donner leur
avis et leurs opinions en disant je ne
veux pas jouer à tel endroit alors
qu'avant c'était j'ai une chance de
jouer en nba je l'apprends et puis on
verra bien ce qui se passe avec c'est
une ligue 2 joueurs c'était mieux avant
et non c'est pas ça c'est en plus c'est
pas vrai parce que l'on fait
kobe bryant a quand même dit qu'il ne
jouerait pas il ne joua jamais
je restais war mais tu sais il est
drafté par reconnaître qu'il
voulait.après ou pas je me remette s'il
a été aussi basculer directement aux
lakers
donc c'est pas vrai que les joueurs ne
faisait pas ça à l'époque mais mais on
l'entend de plus en plus l'année
dernière on l'avait déjà entendu j'ai
plus qui avait refusé à même si ceux ci
a d'ailleurs refusé
j'ai vu des petites déclarations aussi
apparemment mais bon ça n'a pas duré
bien longtemps
ouais peut-être bague les avaient
refusées aussi attendre si je suis à
part montrant très ses démons dit on
sait pas ce qui a été vraiment bon en
tout cas sur le chat on dit si vous
prenez mort hante
il ya certaines personnes qui vont se
remettre à regarder les grizzlies zach
d'un joueur ça peut ça peut aussi faire
du bien alors après c'est pas du tout
great and green door nous mais cela
c'est l'heure de la transition
maintenant deux façons soit aussi à
passer le cap
wen a vu que c'était un petit peu devenu
enfin limitées quoi ce niveau là la
défense on a une bonne défense mais ça
suffit plus à outrepasser les attaques
qui ont pris le pas maintenant seulement
je te remercie d'avoir été avec nous
tony est ce que tu as une dernière
question avant de partir allez une
petite dernière question pour la route
c'est au cas où on réussisse on réussira
pardon à faire un transfert de caunes
les récupérer un pique un peu plus bas
dans ses draps mais lieu en fin de
deuxième deux premiers tours pardon
est ce qu'un joueur comme henriette
chinois pourrait être intéressant j'ai
vu que dans ma fan bei et chris bliss il
ya pas mal de gens qui sont intéressés
par lui donc ce qui serait disponible ce
qui serait intéressant disponible
peut-être intéressant nous on va te
répond nous pas trop on n'aime pas trop
le la transition pour lui ruey tu
mourras c'est un joueur qui jouait
beaucoup déjà à mi distance en nba est
la ligne à ne pas reculer encore donc
celle de quilles après il a un bon shoot
pour sa taille il est taillé comme un
bon poste 3-4 donc
donc il ya un potentiel mais il faut
qu'ils
faut qu'ils comprennent certaines choses
et là où dix on peut être un petit peu
pessimiste c'est que il est quand même
atteindre sa troisième année entier et
que normalement à la fin de la troisième
et a compris ce genre de choses
éducation défensive les voilà à l'est
ouais donc donc après c'est un bon
scoreur voilà il pas il est pas bête
dans le jeu il a montré qu'il pouvait il
était capable d'un peu de driver un peu
de passer mais ça manque ça manque un
petit peu de potentiel presque pour pour
aller plus haut mais mais après ont
chois vince pas une personne va vous
jeter des pierres si vous choisissez la
tu mourras on va peut-être dans un an
bah merci beaucoup merci beaucoup tommy
c'est en quoi mme jabrane du coup on
espère jeudi soir on accueille solal qui
réclamait dans le chat est ce que c'est
bon là assez bon c'est au monde
bah je sais pas je sais pas ça marche
solal fans du tender exactement alors
parle-nous de la situation de ton équipe
qui est qui et qui est pas beaucoup de
marge de manoeuvre financière sylvie
patry
non non non non on est on est à 145
millions de cap et ça va augmenter
l'année prochaine
même avec ceux qui partent donc plus ça
avance et plus les insiders hockey ici
dont d'ombré de houssen et il veut faire
progresser l'équipe pour passer un cap
et dans le même temps un sac ou
de paix mais des salaires parce que
parce que là pour le proprio alors qu'on
se fait on se fait valdinguer au premier
tour trois années d'affilée payer pour
je crois qu'ils payent quelque chose
comme 80 millions de taxes donc
forcément c'est pas acceptable et c'est
clairement son objectif la saint priest
d'accord donc ce que j'ai compris
malgré le fait que sa coupe que on se
dirige plus sur un trade au niveau de la
trappe
bon ok voilà on y arrive et j'ai pas si
les autres vous l'entendez
enregistrement total mais sinon écornée
comme toi ok on a compris
solal que pour toi ça se diriger vers un
trade le soir de la draft etienne
c'était plutôt d'accord c'est le reste à
buy idéale cette situation bien
au-dessus du cap malgré une situation
bien au dessus du cac pendant ce le pic
dans la draft
ça devient compliqué pour récupérer des
joueurs intéressants donc effectivement
falloir faire des moves le soir de la
draft et on ne serait pas étonné que
connaît des petites annonces des
insiders avant que les draps et rennes
ne soit annoncée quand même meiway jeu
ok ici la marge manoeuvre s'est
effectivement décès de remonter
d'essayer de remonter un peu dans cet
instant en par deux trails way ou de
carrément très des lepic je pense que ça
si vous voulez dire voulait dire solal
toi tu aimerais bien solal c'est
quelqu'un que vraiment c'est l'objectif
c'est quand même d'essayer de revenir à
une revenir à une situation financière
saine sologne est au bout de la russie
il ya un décalage horaire mais hello
hello
oui oui et s'entend à le tender de dépôt
petrov
logiquement la voilà je ne bouge plus
valmy ne bouge et voilà restent
orientées comme ceci j'étais en train de
te demander si est ce que tu voulais
quand même si tu traînes le pic est ce
que tu aimerais bien récupérer un autre
ou vraiment c'est pas parce pas là bas
deux toutous les experts draft dont vous
que j'ai lu la la profondeur de la cuvée
de draft de cette année pas pas si
intéressante que ça pour pour chercher
du titulaire
et vu que notre notre fenêtre de tir là
elle se réduit au fur et à mesure que
que westbrook et paul george
vieillissent donc monté dans la draft à
part
à part le top-8 quoi ça aurait pas de
réel intérêt
il vaut mieux il vaut vraiment mieux
aller chercher un joueur qui est déjà
confirmée un vétéran et pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir gagner maintenant puisque
après ça sera trop tard
même s'il se développe alors à qui tu
pense en termes de pour monter ou en
termes de transferts
en termes de temps de terre tu parles
d'un vétéran et quelle équipe serait
preneuse et de qui toi tu serais preneur
pour venir compléter le trident giorgio
s brooke adams du thunder maintenant
avoir dix il arrive enfin à voir
affronte office et sinon c'était super
qui pardon parce qu'on n'a pas entendu
le début table les wizards pardon nous
voudrons rappelé bill d'accord ok d'eau
donc mais il faudrait il faudrait
vraiment vidé l'effectif pour ça et si
non en fait c'est plus se libérer du cap
en soi pour pouvoir utiliser parce que
la note remise le level exception elle
est au plus bas
c'est la luxury tax mais de laval
exception s'ils ont réussi à baisser
notre cap on pourra fournir une mie ça
avait donc attiré claouey iphone danny
green d'accord wayne newton danny green
nos corps on voit vraiment que tu vis du
poste de la free agency c
c'est du morse alex c'est compliqué mais
on a compris à peu près ce que voulait
dire que je suis désolé n'en sais rien
allez on connaît t'inquiète donc plus
des postes de etienne ça te paraît ça ne
paraît pas des collants bas non non
surtout vu duo vie du cinq majeur du
cinq majeur de du thunder qui est juste
pas trop enfin qui rappe l'inamovible
avec peau de jorge luis book lmc crème
des joueurs qui sont difficiles à
dépasser
effectivement il vaut mieux chercher un
poste 2 après j'ai pas trop d'idées en
tête parce que il ne connaissait pas le
cap ellington et green avec l'ami de
level et effectivement c'est ce qui
revient aussi dans le tchat
wayne ellington danny green c'est des
joueurs qui sont free agent
après je partirai je partirai bien sûr a
dit green moi j'aime bien ce joueur ce
style mais ce n'est que mon propre avis
est-ce qu'il ira compliqué vient de
gagner un titre
ben justement après tu as gagné deux
titres de champion nba
justement tu as un peu ça qui rappelons
le les épaules tu attends de voir des
sites mais déjà m et attend de voir
aussi si kawaii reste ou pas est ce que
tu as envie de prolonger est ce que tu
te remets dedans dans la même équipe est
ce que ton et ordina ventura ailleurs
ces décisions qui vont être prises dans
l'est dans les prochaines semaines en
fonction d'eux des joueurs on va dire
majeur des différentes destinations
c'est vrai alors antoine petite
gymnastique intellectuelle
admettons que il ya une équipe qui
arrive à traiter pour pour oklahoma le
pic 21 et admettons que cette équipe se
soit soit les wizzards de soi
bah du coup toronto je sais pas trop
jeune à wellington et où des droits
j'ai pu admettre les wizards qui est ce
que tu vois plus wizards pourraient
drafté à ce moment là pas facile voilà
l'un tient à la volonté et wayne
ellington et bien de toi
wellington est bien gentil hein bah si
je suis les wizards
je vais vouloir un projet à long terme
donc dû kevin porter du genre de joueurs
uniques laxton l'audi victorieuse de
base mais parce que je pense que les
wizards c'est l'équipe dans la pire
situation de la nba actuellement et 6,6
et détroit il y aura peut-être il y aura
peut-être un intérêt justement parce
qu'on parlait tout à l'heure avec avec
le comté faire de détroit et il y avait
quand même pas mal de joueurs qui
étaient visés notamment langford naciri
tu le peut-être même du tiger heroes il
ya pas mal de joueurs qui peuvent être
intéressants pour eux c'est ça manque de
profondeur camin l'e3 donc donc ça peut
ça peut être intéressant je pense mais
c'est ça reste ça reste compliqué ils
sont dans une position assez assez
étrange le thunder ouais ça compliqué et
je crois que que solal nous à nous a dit
au revoir
minée par ses problèmes de connexion
décidément décidément on peut commencer
à parler de phily même si représentants
de six heures s'est refermée pas la
sorte france etienne et qu'il date de la
situation a fait les delphis cas une
grosse équipe donc je suppose que oui
et c'est une grosse équipe ya pas mal de
piquant dans cette draft absolument donc
va mettre pour pour le visuel on va
mettre le résumé pour ceux qui suivent
le live
mais après la situation compliquée
qu'avant parce que c'est quand même cinq
pick dans cette draft mais tu as quand
même pas mal de joueurs qui sont en
période jeunes ou qui sont free agent là
en cette période
enfin en cette fin de saison donc c'est
assez compliqué pour pour philippe qui
va devoir faire un choix qui gardait qui
tu peux garder à quel tarif surtout
qu'ils ont un cap qui est pas énorme
énorme
donc il va falloir faire des bons choix
pour philly qui en plus de ça n'a pas
n'a pas été vraiment à la hauteur des
attentes sur cette saison donc comment
te renforcer autour de deux bennes
simone sedrine mbit/s qu'est ce que tu
fais ce que tu gardes est-ce que l'on va
vouloir rester est-ce que tu gardes
harris reddick compliquer une situation
très compliquée pour finir je troue et
cinq choix antoine qu'est ce qu'on fout
de cinq fois à la barre les traders ont
les traits d'acquis ses bagages soit
cinq fois mais on a pas mal
y en a pas mal le second tour ouais même
oui tu peux se tacher c'est ça que tu y
ailles à 4 juillet quelque chose second
tour donc il ya moins d'aller y est
d'aller chercher des joueurs et de et de
l'east hsa toujours de la valeur je
pense de d'aller chercher du soulman ou
du cjd cette semaine est ok et oui je
pense que services et aux mânes serons
ok quoi mais ils savent que toute façon
ils viennent pas pour rejoindre biais
tout de suite qui miserait retient alors
non je pense et une nouvelle union pour
pour rappeler parce que les gens
connaissent je pense pas bazoumana je
rame aussi un peu hein je tiens à
signaler au cas où c'est avec ça vous
stresse pas c'est à certaines d'y
israélien qui qui s est costaud et que
j'aime beaucoup
voilà rapidement c'est ça
et tout doux qu'est ce que je voulais
dire qu'est ce que je voulais dire c'est
la question sur justin on acheter je
pense que il va traiter du pic pour pour
avoir des second pic d'autres années
quoi je pense que chercher de la
profondeur sur une autre brave 3way
surduts sur le bas 2022 par exemple ça
serait intéressant à ce jour là mm à
double draft même si on n'est toujours
pas sur war n'est toujours pas sûr mais
c'est où il est plus ou moins promis
officieusement adam silver que tu vois
là qu'on allait pouvoir de rester à
partir du lycée et et en 2023 ce à
partir de 2023 en fait que les parties
donc l'association des joueurs peut
sortir du 6 billets actuels il ya une
clause d'opt-out ont diminué de 3 donc à
moins qu'ils aient envie de leur faire
plaisir parce que c'est la première
demande d'une bille pied et c'est un
truc adam silver est prêt à offrir donc
si des planètes s'alignent 2022 cette
draft où c'est très intéressant
d'inventer des kits même au second tour
et oui puisqu'il y aura les lycéens plus
l'espagne c'est ça donc ça sera
intéressant et je crois que la classe
internationale 2022
c'est celle de
le père qu'à signer garuba c'est 2021
[Musique]
exactement je crois et demi de martyrs
je sais plus j'ai un doute
donc c'est pas c'est pas déjà là ça
c'est celle ci mais bon c'est pas leurs
noms mais c'est pour se projeter un peu
donc avec le 24 on en a on en a souvent
discuté parce qu'il ya certains fans de
physique ou postal de questions sur
twitter et du coup ils aiment bien
qu'arsène edwards alors qu'est ce que
t'en pense antoine avec m
elle monte en temps en temps ouais parce
que moi je vous entends saccadé mais on
a gagné
bakar sonné car ce n'est un vase il ya
juste le responsable de six ans qu'il
vient d'arriver mais je crois qu'il est
encore à d'accord si la zizanie carsen
edward bach carson edwards
moi j'aime beaucoup un parce que parce
que c'est un bonheur qu'est ce qu'ils
ont mais ces exemples sont graves en
différé là tout est en double ça faisait
ça tout à l'heure pour pour moi un
moment donné mais ce n'est pas notre
faute
donc je sais pas comment on peut faire
mais je vais quitter la conversation je
vais revenir
ok ça laisse antoine le temps de finir
je disais carson edwards j'aime beaucoup
parce que c'est un séquel ma gagnant ce
qu'il a fait avec purdue la sueur sur
sur la march madness est est quand même
relativement ouf j'avais mis ça dans le
scouting report il me semble je
recherche puis de mémoire sur les trois
matches de march madness v il est à 23
sur 49 à 3 points en trois matches en
trois matches il a pris quasiment
cinquante trois points il en a mis il en
a mis 46% 49% donc
ouais voilà à l'eau il sait ce que c'est
porter une équipe sur son dos à l'eau
entendre dire ah ok merci
est-ce que c'est randy nous a compliqué
oui ça va est ce que tu nous entends en
écho toujours non c'est bon ça a été
réglé
ok on était en train de parler de carson
edward c'est un quelqu'un que vous aimez
bien du côté des sixers non ouais car
seuls les doigts c'est un des proches
que qui revient le plus haut pic 24
d'autant plus qu'il a fait un workout
avec philadelphie où apparemment il
aurait tout explosé alors est rentré
tout c'est tiré apparemment il aurait il
aurait été absolument pas gêné par la
défense de charles match nul donc il a
fait forte impression dans swarthout et
puis au delà de ça c'est un jour qui qui
répond à plusieurs à plusieurs besoins
de de l'effectif donc c'est un des
principal favori pour le pic 24 et oui
le et alors on se posait la question
vous est ce que ça va être plutôt des
pics tâche et le reste est ce que c'est
à dire des joueurs qui restent à
l'étranger pour quelques années ce que
ça va être des pics transférer qu'est ce
que tu en penses que ça dit du côté des
insiders bas il faut savoir que
aujourd'hui drafté on a cinq pick à la
draft et utilise un draft et cinq
joueurs ça c'est difficilement
envisageable puisque signé quatre
joueurs dans le second tour signifierait
sacrifier certaines exceptions du salary
cap pour recruter certains agents libres
donc autant dire que c'est quasiment
acté que les sixers ont drafté le leur
pic maintenant de questions la première
c'est de se demander quel pic vont être
drafté et la deuxième c'est de se
demander est-ce qu'ils vont drafté pour
monter dans cette draft ou pour se
reconstituer un capital pour les années
à venir et je pense que je pense que
philadelphie va monter dans cette draft
et ça m'étonnerait pas que on est deux
pics deux premiers tours d'accord tu
penses que
mais alors à quel niveau ces visées est
ce qu'il ya des joueurs qui sont
particulièrement visés pour dalé parce
que là je regarde un petit peu les
joueurs que vous avez workout n a pas
beaucoup qui sont prévues au delà du pic
enfin plus haut que le pic 25 c'est vrai
que les work out on a pas on n'a pas eu
à par grant williams mais encore là bas
je pense que si on monte dans la draft
ça serait entre le pic fin très proche
d'une optique 24 quoi donc entre le pic
20 et 24 et j'espère en tout cas après
moi je sais mon avis personnel c'est pas
celui de des insiders c'est de tomber
sur tyler héros qui serait un profil qui
pourrait nous intéresser
après il n'y a pas eu beaucoup d'échos
sur une cible prioritaire si on monte
dans la draft a encore c'est quelque
chose encore de très théorique mais mais
c'est quasi certain pour moi que on va
monter mais alors tyler héros selon ce
dont je n'atteins de giffoni qui selon
antoine et est assez proche des inch et
14 sur la dernière moque de johnny c'est
ce qu'on disait hier donc ça laisserait
supposer que qu'à boston on est assez
chaud du côté de pour pour draft et
tyler héros bas d'autant plus qu'il a
été invité à la green room donc je pense
que c'est quasiment impossible de
l'avoir entre 20 et 24 ben c'est sa
vraie et après je ne sais pas quel
profil on pourrait on pourrait avoir
mais c'est sûr que là aujourd'hui aux
sixers de profil qu'il nous faudrait
c'est le twin dit quoi c'est à dire un
joueur qui a des qualités de footing
suffisamment intéressante pour créer un
space in respectable et qui a vraiment
une défense de périmètre mon problème
c'est qu'en 24 on a difficilement des
joueurs qui concilie les deux hôtes de
haut niveau on a des bons défenseurs
comme macky style ou potentiellement au
kéké s'il revient bien de blessure mais
des deux sont pas les qualifier vraiment
menaçants bon shooteur c'est un bon
shooteur mais ça reste fin voilà après
moi vous connaissez mieux que moi mais
je pense que ça reste un shooter
bloquée sur du spot up après haut à
philadelphie et quand on juge un shooter
on s'intéresse surtout à cause des
systèmes de braid bande à sa capacité à
tirer en dehors des écrans et f-22 pour
le dire la française donc après ce que
kick est capable de faire ça je ne sais
pas et et comme je disais les bons
shooteurs en 24 donc et qui a - johnson
carson edwards surtout pour cameron
johnson ya certaines interrogations
interrogations pardon sur sur leur
défense donc on a on est un peu va
falloir faire un choix entre défense et
tire et d'après les dernières rumeurs on
part clairement sur du cha ouais mais
oui c'est plus c'est prioriser un par
beaucoup d équipes du coup sûr du tir
comment ils tirent servi 10 antoine pas
beaucoup joué moins voire pas du tout
bassi services it here pas
exceptionnellement bien de mémoire j'en
ai tellement fait la queue au débotté
je suis un peu un peu rouillé sur serre
et 10 mai de mémoire c'est s était pas
cette première arme
ok mais je peux franchement me tromper
puisque voilà alors à près du cou mais
vous l'annoncer 44e oui oui mais
abondent en ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure entre a passé le pic 25 c'est un
peu chiche bourricot cette voie a pas
mal kif kif bourricot c'est pas ça que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure mais c'est un
peu c'est un peu l'idée
exactement c'est un peu c'est un peu
flou quoi il ya tout un tas de joueurs
qui peuvent partir c'est très difficile
d'en sortir du lot tout le monde
disons qu'on en a certains qui ont des
grosses qualités donc ils vont
certainement partir avant 40 les comme
disait comme disait notre ami des sixers
les tailles leur héros meubles et mathis
title carsen edwards bon ça c'est des
gros shooteur après est-ce que jordan
poulain poste de alors vous et dja
djedje reddick mais jordan poule pour
moi c'est un joueur dont le shoot ce
projet de biens en nba et qu'ils
défendraient correctement à jordan poule
il ya il a froid qui sont leur coach et
c'était aujourd'hui ou hier il n'y a pas
eu d'écho sur sur ce joueur je me suis
parce que simplement intéressés à lui
après c'est difficile de se projeter
parce qu'on est dans une situation
tellement flou 2 par rapport au pic on
ne sait pas si on va les garder ou pas
comme je le dis il ya de grandes chances
que voilà on a cinq pick je pense que
c'est pas impossible que je dis on en
ait de quoi ou 3 way et c'est difficile
de c'est vraiment l'inconnu complète sur
sur ce que va faire les seconds faire
les six heures après personnellement
j'ai je suis assez je suis assez haut
sur sûr qu'arsène edwards
parce que parce que il a cette
polyvalence offensive qui est
intéressant c'est à dire que il a la
capacité d'évoluer au football et la
porte et une certaine gravité
c'est un assez bon shooteur et lui peut
tirer en dehors des écrans il a un style
qui peut potentiellement se rapprocher à
celui djédjé roddick
donc autant dire que dans les systèmes
de bras de brosne il va s'épanouir et il
a un autre truc qui manque cruellement
aux sixers aussi et que je sais pas bon
après ça allait je comptais vous imposez
je comptais vous pose ces questions
s'est il à la création offensive il est
capable de créer quelque chose fin du
mois il en a montré quelques flashs et
et ça c'est quelque chose qui manque
cruellement aux sixers quoi je vois là
c'est tout bête mais il est capable de
poulpe à trois points bon après c'est
pas quelque chose qu'on peut on peut
qualifier comme sûrs à 100% mais il a il
a cette possibilité là et le pool a pas
trois points la création française c'est
quelque chose qui compte énormément aux
playoffs parce que en playoffs des
shooteurs qui tourne à 37 ou 38 % en
spots hop on va aller défier on va on va
là
poussée à shooter et les qualités de on
va les joueurs sont beaucoup plus amenés
à créer par eux mêmes donc la claque ou
pour soi c'est pas un problème c'était
un peu plus la création pour les autres
qui part je pense pas que j'aurai alors
que de ce côté là il y là il aura pas
besoin de larmes pas trop de
responsabilités d'accord donc toi c'est
il faut vraiment un scoreur un scoreur
au micro ondes comme des c'est ça et il
nous faudrait aussi une fin après je
sais pas si car ça ne te remplir ce rôle
mais la défense de périmètre c'est
quelque chose qui nous a cruellement
manqué aux sixers parce que parce que
parce que derrière smith a été blessé
toute la saison est bon il est revenu en
fin de saison il a joué quelques matches
mais c'est vrai que c'est un besoin qui
s'est fait cruellement sentir
et de manière générale le ben quoi c'est
on est une équipe qui a et on avait des
attentes extrêmement élevé on était
candidat pour le titre mais je pense que
de toutes les autres
de toutes les équipes candidats pour le
titre on a très facilement le pire bon
quoi et c'est un peu paradoxal avec
cette draft c'est à dire d'un côté on
est obligé de d'être aidé nos pics et de
l'autre on a des besoins tellement
important que qu'il nous faudrait
plusieurs picot c'est la question
j'avais posé justement redit comment
comment tu évalues la situation ton
équipe actuelle avec tous ces joueurs
qui sont free agent ou qui ont la
possibilité de prendre leur plaire
option comment est ce que tu vois un
petit peu est-ce qu'il va falloir
combler rapidement à tous les postes
ou est-ce que tu en vois certains hocini
serait engagé avec les sixers bas c'est
vrai que c'est une situation compliquée
c'est le flou complet
parce que bon on a sacrifié un nombre
non négligeable pour pas dire quasiment
tous nos assiettes pour recruter deux
stars qui sont aux biens services et jim
butler et le risque de entre guillemets
repartir à zéro il est pas négligeable
maintenant moi je pense que le ya un
vrai risque qu'aucun des deux ne racing
et je pense que les six heures devrait
vraiment se se grandir se protéger de ça
en draft en non seulement des joueurs
qui ont
un plancher assez élevé pour pouvoir
impact est tout de suite mais aussi un
potentiel élevé pour pouvoir les
développer et les traits d pour ramener
d'autres stars je suis vraiment pas
chaud pour drafté des joueurs qui à la
carcel à la cameron johnson qui vont un
plancher élevé tout de suite on sait
qu'ils vont apporter je crois vraiment
privilégié le potentiel de développement
les joueurs qui peuvent avoir une
vraiment de valeur sur le marché comme
matisse table parce que parce que tonton
capital d'ascète a été mise à mal et
pour faire face aux incertitudes de
l'avenir les incertitudes vis-à-vis de
dessiner des resignature t2t star je
pense qu'il faut garder un minimum de
flexibilité et c'est pour ça que j'avais
dit tout à l'heure que je prie que je
préférais que les sixers draft pour
trait pour se reconstituer un capital
d'ascète pour les années à venir au lieu
de compter dans ses droits c'est
vraiment pour garder une une flexibilité
par rapport à l'avenir parce que je
pense que il ya un vrai risque qu'aucun
des donneurs aussi et oui et c c'est
quand même dommage finalement d'avoir
dilapidé tout ça pour six mois de
personnes effectivement ce n'est pas
juste les assets qu'ils ont dilapidé
c'est juste 4 5 en deux saisons en nba
où il y longtemps quéau
bah oui c'est possible en des boutons à
peu près tous les fans des six ans pour
essayer d'arriver à cette saison où ils
ont quatre stars dans leur dans leur
effectif sans arriver en demi finale bah
après je suis pas complètement d'accord
avec ce que tu dis parce que déjà d'une
part il ya des équipes qui comme keith
ont éclaté depuis quatre ans et qui est
le saurons pour les quatre années à
venir encore les sixers
on a eu la chance d'avoir au moins deux
doigts de s'être donné les moyens d'être
au niveau et puis tout n'est pas tout il
faut être un peu optimiste fauci
bateleurs et tobias à riespach on a
quand même une vaste bensen bensen c'est
joël mg bid et beaucoup de caps
donc il ya toujours la possibilité
d'être un candidat sérieux au titre pour
les années à venir mais c'est clair que
on le sera beaucoup moins dangereux pour
les années à venir et que si demain
tobias harris et du mil butler s'en va
on sera plus en comptant on sera plus un
candidat
absolument et donc pour pour l'epiq 42
54 c'est pas du tout sûr que vous pitié
mais ce que dans l'hypothèse où butler
s'en aille
d'ailleurs est ce que dans cette
hypothèse là il faudrait pas drafté des
joueurs justement qu'ils puissent
défendre périmètre oui il faut des fois
il faudra adapter les joueurs qui
puissent devenir email et quand je dis
aux périmètres c'est défendre des grands
ailiers genre de choses bah c'est en
fait c'est un peu compliqué on est dans
une situation compliquée parce que c'est
à dire que finalement nos besoins à la
draft ils sont influée par la signature
ou non de certains joueurs et de ce
point de vue là je trouve ça
complètement stupide que la draft soit
gants avant la prière jeûne type parce
que bon bah les choix de des joueurs
vont déterminer nos besoins comme tu
l'as dit si butler s'en va il est
évident qu'on aura un besoin de deux
défenses de périmètre et à l'inversé
tobiana art et s'en va on aura faudra
prioriser le shooting
maintenant c'est vrai que la qualité
principale à remplacer s'ils battent
leurs 120 c'est la défense de périmètre
mais pour ça je m'en veux dire on décale
cette responsabilité a dit hier smith
mais c'est surtout la création offensive
quoi parce que c'est quelque chose qui
en dehors de leur manque cruellement aux
six heures the peut pas viser le titre
si t'as pas un joueur capable de créer
offensivement et ça s'est vu d'ailleurs
à quel point butler a été important pour
nous cette année
donc si vous êtes leur sauvage que
j'aurais tendance à privilégier un
quelqu'un qui peut peser offensivement
pour lui-même ou pour les autres
et d'ailleurs c'était une des questions
que je voulais vous poser c'est à dire
en dehors de carson edwards
quel joueur a un potentiel de création
offensive fin de premier tour ou dans le
second tour antoine ce qui est non
sur les créations
bah moi je dirais je dirais bien paru se
basent les du cou qui qui est vrai qu'un
répète un peu une forme ward du voilà
après sur les autres postes
on va dire on va y avoir surtout des
meneurs donc bah c'est ce qu'on disait
on ne sait pas qui a quelle équipe on
disait tout à l'heure
parmi les meneurs ont d'abord créateur
tu avais déjà bien installée justin
robinson the warriors non j'ai bien oui
du coup du coup je vais peut-être tabler
sur des sur des choix comme ça ouais
chamond riponne c'est mon iphone crise
récente reproche aux disciples ouais
ouais son propre shoot c'est surtout ça
que vous voulez lire je crois audi après
mais c'est évidemment le genre de profil
plus tu recules dans la draft plus tu
vas drafté des gens qui sont
potentiellement plus des rôles players
que des gens et leurs shoots en est
d'ailleurs tu aimes bien tyler héros
métro il crée pas son shoot le voient
plus en lui un potentiel de création de
de tirs que ou de création de dire cela
ce score que de que par exemple un jour
qui peut tomber à 24 comme thiam ron
johnson awalaq m.cameron johnson
d'ailleurs c'est le nôtre
condé et sixers juste plus qu'elle
sixers funds nous a mentionné sur
twitter apparemment il a fait un mort
quatre hommes hors cadre privé voilà je
serais assez déçus s'ils ont drafté
cameron johnson je te laisse pas parce
que c'est un joueur qui est assez
unidimensionnel en tout cas et le
sevrage france et la valeur de ces
joueurs là en playoffs parce que leurs
rentes ai enfin leur valeur sur le
terrain ne dépend que de leurs tirs et
le chou tchèque sol ce qui est soumis à
des variables aléatoires donc en
playoffs
autant dire que si tu ne rentres pas tu
ne sers à rien c'est le cas pour les
rangers puisque et derrière il y peut
pas compenser par sa défense absolument
on demande un avis sur ignacio d'ekis
alors c'est pareil c'est pas un joueur
qui peut créer pour lui même même si on
l'a vu dans des situations de pick and
roll cette année j'en ai parlé un petit
peu tout à l'heure c'est un joueur qui
est assez costaud qu'un peu tank et dont
le corps est prêt pour la nba est assez
agréable à voir jouer quasiment d'apt
pas mal de facilité a alors même si ça
se voit pas forcément d'un pourcentage à
finir près du cercle des douches c'est
assez beau un shoot correct une belle
mécanique d'ailleurs un peu compact ça
se sait pour ma partie antoine je te
laisse compléter sur brasse des kiss
c'est une question du chat de damian la
question du chat de damien sur base des
kiss bahout a dit pas mal de choses
après c'est surtout un sur ce cap et ce
texte crée son propre shoot une bille et
j'y crois pas c'est un joueur de devoir
je pense qu'il faut on aime rarement les
comparaisons mais j'ai minci de
comparaison avec gérer quoi même si
c'est pas la même taille
l'homme à tout faire quoi c'est et voilà
c'est le boy next door qui va t'aider
est ce que c'est ça dont on a besoin
fini je suis pas sûr mais ils ont
tellement de piques que ça peut être
intéressant
on soit d'avoir des joueurs au profil un
peu varié et puis c'est la gorge et
devra se décrit sans ouais il est encore
jeune et puis c'est peut-être
intéressant d'avoir un gars qui est un
peu une tête de méchant dans les films
tu m'as raid si je me trompe roadie mais
il ya peut-être un peu trop de gentils
heureusement qu'ils avaient jimmy butler
cette année quoi dû me botte leur dû me
battre leurs jouets lembit belle simons
non c'est des gens qui sont qui sont
très sérieux et agressif quand il faut
l'être ce côté après ce bon assez sûr
que butler et un côté un peu atypique
mais je ne pense pas qu'on manque de
caractère on dire ok bah écoute brasse
des kystes voilà une idée nous demande
aussi est-ce que le tiger heroes est un
land riches à mettre bis déjà lambrichs
à m il arrive à mettre ses mains dans
ses poches
mais sinon moi je trouve pas parce que
j'aime pas trop tailleur héros mais
après il y en a qui l'adorent
j'ai vu des dépisteurs may day leurs
héros dans leur top 10 ans donc
donc c'est des choses qui arrivent et je
pense qu'en ce sens le traiter l'eau sur
son shoot cdg son choix des maires que
ces pourcentages ont baissé pension mais
il fait un très bon shooteur mais voilà
tout quoi mouassa qui s'est planté un
peu sur certains matches un peu cruche
et c'est peut-être pour ça que superbe
touche et il n'y a pas de souci il
prendre les bonnes décisions c'est un
rôle player pour moi je pense pas qu'il
serait plus enviée ouais mais bon si tu
drafts comme certains le semble penser
dans la loterie tête espère peut-être un
peu plus qu'un européen
moi j'ai lu deux trottoirs la gauche
après je sais pas ce lancement n'ont pas
forcément mais vous juger j'ai lu du
compte d'un potentiel square je sais pas
si c'est oui ou non mais c'est il a
effectivement potentiel scoreur mais
après et cette espèce de mythologie
qu'est en train de se mettre en place
comme quoi john calipari briderait
absolument tous ces joueurs et du coup
tous vont exploser après un millier
pas forcément donc oui donc pas
forcément mais mais il a eu des
responsabilités de kiki son dancing on
va dire sous le sceau kelly paris
puisque il est très exigeant y avoir eu
ses responsabilités ou par ces
responsabilités là c'est que c'est
quelque part il ya une certaine solidité
ne serait-ce que mentale quoi et la
solidité mentale c'est bien c'est vrai
c'est un garçon qui allait droit dans
ses baskets europe il ya d'autres
questions
ouais j'ai plusieurs questions voilà
vas-y déjà la première c'était
concernant dia smith est ce que vous
voyez en lui un potentiel offensif qui
va au-delà du simple mais voilà qui est
présent pour écarter le terrain à trois
points en plus plus directement est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est à sa très
intéressant de développer de l'asthme et
siècle ballon ait pas ça serait
intéressant puisqu'on l'a jamais vu avec
le ballon dans les mains
même moi j'ai pas de souvenir de zaïre
smith qui jouent en pick and roll par
exemple non mais parce que je disais ça
parce que l'année dernière où il avait
montré certains flash en termes de
création athlétique
enfin de création à critiquer ce que je
raconte de création offensif grâce à ses
qualités athlétiques où vous voyez il
est temps en temps il d'arriver il
pousse un stade bas qui a trait bioland
je sais que la création française
c'était quelque chose de convoyer
potentiellement chez ce joueur bah
disons que on va dire que les qualités
athlétiques pour créer c'est à dire tu
sais quand tu drive pour s'arrêter d'un
coup il faut des qualités athlétiques
très très forte
tout simplement une fin au niveau
musculaire etc donc ça évidemment il l'a
après il faut aussi de la technique et
c'est plus la queue
que c'est compliqué parce qu'il me
semble que hertz mais ça fait pas si
longtemps que ça qui joue au basket dans
ma mémoire
non c'est ça donc donc oui moi je te dis
oui oui il va pouvoir se créer un petit
shoot à mi distance quand sur un stop
assez rapide et puis mon but qui
montrent assez haut sur son tir en
suspension et bien ça va ça lui permet
de se créer de l'espace se crée de
l'espace oui mais après il faut que met
le shoot il faut arriver à se créer de
l'espace en reste en équilibre et en
gardant à l'esprit ce qui se passe
autour de soi et ça c'est des choses
qu'il est tard pour apprendre il va les
pros si je te dis pas que dans trois
quatre ans il sera pas capable de le
faire mais de lui demander ça dès
l'année prochaine ça me parle au nom
mais c'est parce que on est tellement la
situation est tellement critiqué en
termes de création offensif que j'en
suis a à proposer des solutions
désespérées
oui aux critiques servent à quoi la
juste une heure de jeu c'est une petite
remarque qui n'a absolument rien à voir
avec la franchise on vient d'apprendre
qu'un seul médecin et de signer re
signer son contrat à 27 millions sont
six nations avec mes amis ceux qui
écoutent et qui un petit coucou à à
simon qui est le fan de miami qui
étaient avec nous hier qui s'attendait
évidemment à cette signature puisque
jamais il aurait gagné 27 millions
ailleurs traminer san road y est ce que
tu as une autre question va on va pas
tarder à conclure on en est là sur le
potentiel dauphin quelle conscience vous
avez sur le développement du tir de faim
développement su être un grand mot mais
sur machiste et vol offensivement
parlant l'année prochaine ça donne quoi
c'est sain spacing killer où c'est moins
pire que ce que ce qu'on veut aller
antoine pour pour la dernière question
de ce live
antoine
coût 1
étouffé par son saucisson eh bah oui
mais c'est le risque s'il enlève pas la
peau maty style ça a été un bon shooteur
et c'est ça qui est bizarre parce que
normalement le shoot ça s'améliore petit
à petit et je suppose que tu as vu comme
nous c'est ces pourcentages retire sa
saison sophomore il à 40% à 3 points
quasiment alors après il faut plus
regarder
nous ce qu'on regarde plus c'est
évidemment le pourcentage aux lancers
francs
le pourcentage à 3 points ce sera
peut-être plus intéressant l'année
prochaine du clouding va reculer en
mennecier mai mais le pourcentage aux
lancers francs donne une indication
historiquement plus précises sur la
réussite à trois points que que le
pourcentage à 3 points donc le
pourcentage aux lancers francs de matty
style je suis en train présentement de
le chercher parce que je les ai pas en
tête
il est à 85% je crois de mémoire ou 80
quelque chose comme ça sur un peu plus
de tentatives ouais il dit gilles hâlais
très peu tu réunis alors ça déjà c'est
un petit peu problématique pour un
joueur qui est la bad and ont peu de
rêve et s'il a un petit haendel je le
trouve très limite en interne de drague
il drive que quand c'est très droit fin
la ligne elle est très drôle où il est
mais il a su parfois faire des petits
trip dans les petits espaces
alors c'était évidemment c'était pas la
violence et francy fait le yoyo 71 84 71
85 pas c'est pas terrible après pas
beaucoup de tentatives donc ça peut
expliquer la variance mais moi si je
devais mettre maman au feu je pense que
c'est un mec qui plafonne à 35% en nba
ah oui ok mais pas madame irma et on
s'est trompé plein de fois par le passé
on se tromperait encore dans le futur et
donc
ouais je sais pas quoi dire là dessus
c'est et c'est vraiment franchement si
c'est un shooteur draft dans le top10
presque qua non mais c'était parce que
c'est un nom qui revient énormément
mathis taiba let car ce n'est devancé
peut-être les deux noms qui reviennent
le plus est que beaucoup sont très
freiné par par le fait de draft et parce
que il peut potentiellement tuer ton
speaking est dans une équipe où ben
sigmund ses joies les mid ont
cruellement besoin de sting pour
exceller offensivement
après moi je hmm hmm hmm en sa chance en
ça je pense à je pense que je prendrai
les deux je prends le risque de le draft
et parce que je pense que le stade il
est trop basse et maintenant le
peut-être que vraiment le tt sur de
draft est un défenseur qui est
potentiellement fringe all defensive
team québécois et puis s'ils arrivent à
développer un choix intéressant ça ça
change beaucoup de choses pour pour lui
absolument
absolument merci beaucoup rodi eh ben
c'est avec plaisir et deviennent aussi
juste juste derrière chose là bas
qu'avant j'ai appris plein de trucs bien
sympathique de participer à blaye il ya
juste quelque chose qu'il faut préciser
parce qu'on parlait tout à l'heure de
thé king's avec que notre ami harrison
barnes
ils font savoir que du coup le fait
qu'ils ne prennent pas son option avec
les kings ça libère jusqu'à 60 millions
de cap
et oui les noms du monde du monde dans
le porte monnaie
voilà donc du coup ils ont ils ont un
peu de marge de manoeuvre
du côté de la californie absolument
absolument et il ya des questions qui se
posent sur sur plusieurs sur plusieurs
resignature surplus sur quelques
signatures on en a parlé tout à l'heure
avec les kings on vous envoie bas à la
réécoute de ce live qui sera disponible
juste après que j'ai coupé le micro
c'est à dire dans 5 4 3 2 1 à demain
bocsa haut